Er taucht auf! Er taucht aus den Fluten auf! Der berühmte Drache aus dem Drachental taucht auf! Och, der sieht ja reizend aus! Ich bin gespannt, ob der Drache auch Feuer speien wird. Oh, das wäre fantastisch! Wundervoll wäre das, wenn du das machen würdest!
Na, seid ihr nun zufrieden?
Was soll das Papa? Was haben dir die Armtouristen getan?
Nicht das geringste, aber wegen des Drachenfeuers sind sie doch von weit her gekommen.
Papa, du solltest dich wirklich schämen. Ich versteh dich nicht. Wie kannst du der Neugier der Touristen auch noch entgegenkommen?
Was heißt denn entgegenkommen?
Die Welt der Drachen ist tot und du tust, als ob wir Drachen noch eine Zukunft hätten.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 153. Mein Name Tim Pritlove, soweit alles wie gehabt. Und ja, heute bin ich mal wieder unterwegs. Eine ausführliche Podcastreise, die ihre Hindernisse hatte, die ich aber alle meistern werde, gemeistert habe und mich dann auch gleich in den Süden Deutschlands gebracht hat. Genau genommen verweile ich hier gerade in Lörrach, unweit von Basel, wo es dann heute auch noch mal ein kleines Hörer-Treffen geben wird, da freu ich mich schon drauf. Aber erst mal kommt hier die Pflicht vor der Kür. Und das heißt, eine neue Sendung ist angesagt. Das Thema heute ist Feuerwehr. Feuerwehren, Freiwillige Feuerwehren, andere Feuerwehren, Feuerwehrtechnik, all das, was so um Feuerwehr herumspuckt. Und da ich da wieder mal, wie immer, keine Ahnung von habe, frage ich mal lieber jemand, der da ein bisschen tiefer drinsteckt und begrüße für Chaosradio Express den Peter, Peter Schwindt. Hallo.
Hallo Tim.
In unseren Kreisen auch als VT100 bekannt. Du bist ja auch ganz umtriebig im digitalen Umfeld. Das ist ja auch dein Job. Aber du bist auch so im CCC vor allem bekannt, weil du dafür sorgst, dass JABBA ccc.de funktioniert.
Genau.
Also der JABBA-Server, den der Club vor einiger Zeit bereitgestellt hat und der ja auch jedem offen steht. Weiß gar nicht, ob das jeder weiß. Und der wie viele User jetzt mittlerweile hat? Viele?
Viele.
Mehr Informationen gibt es da nicht. Genau. Der Datenschutz. Nicht der Datenschutz, aber die Gründe sind sicher bekannt. Keine Begehrlichkeiten weg.
Okay. Keine Begehrlichkeiten weg. Aber es ist schon ein bisschen was unterwegs. Es gibt schon ein bisschen was zu administrieren. Und wer Lust hat, kann sich da halt auch einen Account machen. Ja, aber davon abgesehen hast du auch noch so eine ganz analoge Seite an dir. Und bist du, wie soll man sagen, bist du schon immer, seit wann machst du denn das so mit Feuerwehr?
Mit der Feuerwehr seit, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich sag jetzt mal grob, seit ich 15 bin. Also damals mit Jugendfeuerwehr angefangen. Sozusagen rangezüchtet und dann irgendwann, wenn es dann mal soweit ist, nach den passenden Lehrgängen einfach zu den Aktiven gewechselt und dann dort sozusagen das richtige Geschäft aufgenommen. Also sind jetzt mittlerweile auch schon irgendwie...
Warum?
Warum? Damals in der Jugend kommt man natürlich dazu, weil es irgendwie meistens, weil einfach Freunde hingehen und jetzt sagen, komm doch mal mit, macht Spaß. Und die Spaßsache bleibt und irgendwann bleibt man dann...
Die Freunde gehen?
Die Freunde sind auch dabei geblieben und irgendwann bleibt man einfach dabei, wechselt dann zu den Aktiven und hat weiterhin seinen Spaß dran. Und je nachdem, wie sehr man sich dann dort engagieren will, das ist wie in jedem Hobby, kann man dann irgendwie auch noch mehr Zeit da drin verbringen und noch mehr Jobs machen, als nur einfach irgendwie Feuermann zu sein. Und so läuft das dann jetzt, wie gesagt, wir hatten es jetzt. Das sind es jetzt von 15 bis 18 Jahre.
Also schon eine Weile. Freiwillige Feuerwehr.
Freiwillige Feuerwehr.
Also es war jetzt auch eigentlich gar nicht deine Intention, Berufsfeuerwehrmann zu werden. Aber warum will man da hin? Also jetzt nur weil die anderen Freunde da... Ich meine, das wird ja jetzt allein nicht ausgereicht haben. Muss sich da ja auch schon irgendwas gehalten haben.
Ja, also am Anfang, also wir merken selber, wenn man jetzt irgendwie auch ausbildet in der Jugendfeuerwehr, ist man muss einfach den Kids was bieten, dass sie da bleiben. Also muss ihnen Spaß machen, man muss irgendwie sie mit der Technik locken, mit den Inhalten. Und man muss das Ganze früh genug anfangen, weil sonst hat irgendwie schon der Fußballverein, die Schüler irgendwie, die ganzen geklaut. Und der klaut sie natürlich auch dann richtig für einmal die Woche Training und Wochenende auch meistens. Und da muss man einfach einen Gegenpol liefern und um die Jugendlichen an der Stange zu halten, dass sie Interesse daran haben und das Interesse behalten. Und am besten natürlich auch soweit, dass sie dann auch nachher in den aktiven Dienst auch übertreten werden, dass sich das dann auch gelohnt hat.
Ja, wie viele Leute bleiben? Wie viele Leute gehen wieder?
Was würde ich jetzt bei uns sagen? Also ich denke mal, von denen, die eintreten, Hälfte bis zwei Drittel, machen dann wirklich weiter.
Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Quote, oder?
Das ist auch wirklich eine der Hauptlieferstellen sozusagen für den Nachwuchs in der Feuerwehr. Also Quereinsteiger sind erstaunlich selten. Leute, die einfach irgendwann mal aus der Gemeinschaft irgendwie raussagen, ich will zur Feuerwehr, die schon irgendwie 30 sind, das ist halt enorm selten. Dass irgendjemand da noch übersteigt. Die meisten kommen halt aus der Jugendfeuerwehr. Und sie halten sie dabei und dann steht es auf.
Auf einer Seite mit Fußballvereinen, wie du schon sagtest, und die Banken wollen uns ja auch ganz früh haben und die Versicherungen überhaupt. Ja, also jeder, der jung ist und zuhört, sie sind hinter dir her. Auch die Feuerwehr. Aber Feuerwehr ist toll, sagst du.
Ja, es macht mir noch Spaß.
Und wie ist denn das überhaupt? Also es gibt eine Berufsfeuerwehr und es gibt eine freiwillige Feuerwehr. Wo geht denn das zusammen bzw. wo ist denn das? Und auf welche Art und Weise ist denn das überhaupt getrennt? Also wodurch wird eine Feuerwehr freiwillig oder wodurch wird sie eine Berufsfeuerwehr? Kannst du mal so ein bisschen Einblick geben, wie das eigentlich so strukturiert ist in Deutschland? Oder, wenn du es auch von anderen Ländern weißt, aber das ist wahrscheinlich primär von Deutschland, ne?
Genau, ich kann es jetzt primär von Deutschland sagen. Da ist es verhältnismäßig einfach geklärt. Eine Gemeinde, eine Stadt, ab 100.000 Einwohnern muss sozusagen eine Berufsfeuerwehr haben. Sie ist dann einfach verpflichtet, eine zu stellen. Eine Feuerwehr wird schon ab viel weniger Einwohnern, wird sie schon hauptamtliche Kräfte haben. Vielleicht einen hauptamtlichen Kommandanten oder ein paar Gerätewarte, die sich schauen, dass das ganze Zeug, die ganze Ausrüstung am Leben bleibt. Aber ab einer gewissen Größe ist einfach eine Gemeinde verpflichtet, eine Stadt dann eine Berufsfeuerwehr zu stellen, zu haben. Dann wird die dann eingerichtet, aber es hat dann auch immer parallel in den Orten auch weiterhin eine Freiwillige zur Unterstützung, weil eine Berufsfeuerwehr nie so viele Leute haben kann, wie sie jetzt im selben Ort eine Freiwillige hätte.
Also auch in großen Städten?
Ja, Berlin hat auch eine Freiwillige Feuerwehr.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht nur eine, oder?
Genau.
Ist das dann immer so regional, immer so Stadtteil?
Genau, das wird stadtteilbezogen sein, ganz einfach. Dass dann halt ein Löschzug in Hohenschönhausen oder was auch immer gibt oder in Stadtwache irgendwo.
Aber wer finanziert denn diese Freiwilligenfeuerwehren? Ich meine, das ist ja tolles Zeug.
Genau, muss durch die Gemeinde bezahlt werden. Muss? Ja, die Gemeinde zahlt, stellt die Ausrüstung, den ganzen Zustand sozusagen, den ganzen Sachstand der Feuerwehr. Mit Zuschüssen vom Land natürlich. Man kann für Fahrzeuge, für Bauten irgendwie Zuschüsse kriegen unter gewissen Voraussetzungen, wie überall. Dann gibt es irgendwie Gelder dazu. Aber grundsätzlich ist die Gemeinde verpflichtet, das Geld dafür locker zu machen.
Das heißt, so für jetzt rein aus finanzieller Sicht ist es für die Gemeinde eigentlich kein großer Unterschied, eine Berufsfeuerwehr und eine Freiwillige Feuerwehr?
Kann ich jetzt von den Preisen nicht sagen, aber Berufsfeuerwehr schlägt natürlich nachher die Personalkosten wahnsinnig rein. Wenn dann irgendwie 30, 40, 50 Aktive dort bezahlt werden müssen, dann müssen hauptamtliche Kosten natürlich. Andererseits, ich sag jetzt mal, wenn wir drunter sind, sagen wir mal 50.000, wird es trotzdem drei, vier, fünf Hauptamtler geben, mindestens. Die Fahrzeuge sind aber trotzdem schon da. Also die Fahrzeuge macht es nachher keinen großen Schritt mehr. Aber es braucht halt nachher eine Unterkunft, weil die müssen ja während sie in Diensten auch irgendwo wohnen, schlafen, essen. Also ist nachher schon ein gewisser Schritt. Aber letztendlich bleibt auch das natürlich an der Gemeinde hängen. Die aber dafür mehr Service hat, sprich sie hat Feuerwehrleute natürlich auf Abruf da und muss sie nicht erst von zu Hause irgendwie zusammenklingeln. Hat natürlich Vorteile.
Okay, also Berufsfeuerwehr muss gestellt werden von größeren Gemeinden und gibt es dann auch so einen klaren Schlüssel, wie viele? Also ich meine, wenn es dann auch sonst noch Freiwillige gibt, ist ja die Frage, wie viele Berufsfeuerwehren muss sie haben? Also ich meine, muss sie dann, weiß ich, ganz Berlin so, wir haben mehr als 100.000 Einwohner, jetzt brauchen wir auch noch eine Berufsfeuerwehr, da sitzt man da so fünf Hansels hin und so, ja, hier haben wir unsere Berufsfeuerwehr.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Also Berlin hat schon eine Berufsfeuerwehr, Berlin.
Die aber wahrscheinlich auch mehrere Standorte hat.
Die auch mehrere Standorte hat, also wie die Freiwilligen selber. Damit sie alles innerhalb der gesetzlich vorgegebenen Fristen erreichen. Das geht jeder Feuerwehr so. Daran muss man sich messen lassen und daran wird auch letztendlich gemessen, und auch die Ausstattung und gesagt, okay, hier müssen wir jetzt irgendwie noch ein Gerätehaus hinsetzen, weil wir haben irgendwie diese Fläche abzuarbeiten und in dem Bereich müssen die erste Fahrzeuge in 15 Minuten da sein. Und es geht halt nur, wenn dort auch ein Fahrzeug dauerhaft steht.
Okay, das heißt, man analysiert schon, was ist sozusagen der Bedarf anhand von Gebäuden, Bewohnern, Erreichbarkeit, etc.?
Genau, das analysieren, knallhart auch die Versicherungen im Nachhinein, wenn es dann hieß, da hätte aber eine Feuerwehr innerhalb von so uns viel mutigen da sein müssen, die war nicht da, jetzt ist irgendwie mehr abgebrannt, als hätte können oder hätte sollen. Also die sind natürlich dahinter, um für sich, klar, das ziel der Versicherung kosten zu sparen natürlich.
Feuerwehr ist ja auch so eine klassische Errungenschaft der Zivilisation, so dieses, man baut so Städte und irgendwann fangen sie ans Brennen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann ist das? Weißt du da was zu dieser Geschichte, also wann das eigentlich so losgegangen ist?
Das müsste ich selber jetzt nachschauen. Also könnte ich jetzt so aus dem Kopf gar nicht sagen, jetzt im Jahr so und so viel hat es die erste Feuerwehr in Deutschland gegeben.
Na darum, aufs Jahr würde es mir jetzt auch nicht ankommen. Aber im Prinzip hat sich das wahrscheinlich aus so einer freiwilligen Tradition heraus auch entwickelt.
Also ich denke, dass es halt früher irgendwie, es hat halt irgendwo gebrannt und ist mal hingerannt. Früher hat dann Dita vielleicht seinen Eimer mitgenommen und dann geguckt, dass er Wasser reinschöpft. Und irgendwann hat man halt gesagt, ja, wir wollen aber irgendwie ein Fahrzeug, wo man mehr Wasser drauf werfen können. Oder man ist dann halt irgendwie mit der Kutsche, mit der Pumpe hinten drauf, wo dann sechs Leute noch die Pumpenschwängel drücken mussten. Ist dann damit einfach gekommen. Und dann irgendwann gab es natürlich Ausrüstung dazu. Das heißt, die Leute wollten halt eine gewisse Art Schutzkleidung. Und so ist das dann einfach durch die Jahre, durch die Technik natürlich gewachsen. Und durch die bessere Ausrüstung. Und natürlich an den Leuten hängt es immer noch. Es müssen immer noch Leute sein, Personen sein, die Interesse daran haben. Dann, wenn es denn soweit ist, auch zu kommen und zu helfen natürlich.
Aber so dieses Modell, dass jetzt eine gesellschaftliche Dienstleistung zu so einem großen Teil von Freiwilligen geleistet wird, weiß nicht, kann man das auf irgendeinen Anteil runterbrechen? Wie viel Prozent jetzt so diese Freiwilligenfeuerwehren ausmachen? Also angenommen alle Freiwilligenfeuerwehren werden weg. Wie viel Schlagkraft würde die Feuerwehr verlieren? Alle Freiwilligen wären weg.
Das hieße dann, dass man, wenn man hier unten schaut, hier die südliche Erdebadung Württembergs, dann wäre dann die nächste Feuerwehr in Freiburg. Viel Spaß.
Also mit anderen Worten, riesige Gebiete sind eigentlich nur überhaupt von Freiwilligenfeuerwehren abgedeckt.
Genau, dadurch, dass wir halt die 100.000-Personengrenze haben oder 100.000-Einwohner-Grenze so rum. Ja, heißt dann, okay, die nächste Feuerwehr ist jetzt mal, wenn sie Gas geben, irgendwie eine dreiviertel Stunde entfernt.
Finde das erstaunlich, dass das so funktioniert? Was macht so diese Feuerwehrwelt aus, dass die da so gut sich selbst organisieren kann?
Einerseits ist es auch, fangen wir nochmal von hinten an, einerseits ist es der Zwang der Gemeinden, eine Feuerwehr zu stellen. Also wir hatten es nicht nur mit den 100.000 Einwohnern, sondern eine Gemeinde muss eine freiwillige Feuerwehr stellen. Wenn sie die nicht hat, gibt es eine Pflichtfeuerwehr. Das ist dann die allerletzte Stufe. Wenn es dann keine Freiwilligen mehr hat, ist die Gemeinde verpflichtet, eine sogenannte Pflichtfeuerwehr zu stellen. Und dann geht es halt los, dass die Gemeinde irgendwie einmal ans Register geht, alle Einwohner zwischen X und X anschreibt. Also ihr müsst jetzt dann und dann antreten zum Feuerwehrdienst.
Ach echt?
Das gab es auch schon mal in Deutschland.
In einer Gemeinde, die nicht... Ich meine, warum? Weil sie nicht willens war, weil sich keine freiwillige Feuerwehr gefunden hat.
Ja, ich glaube, da war aber sogar noch ein bisschen Trick dabei. Also sie wollten aus einem bestimmten Grund... Ich habe gesagt, wir machen halt nicht mehr mit. Ich müsste genau nachgucken. Also die ALWI ist eine Müllhalde, weiß da sicher mehr drüber.
Okay, aber auf jeden Fall ist es so... Das Gesetz stellt sicher, dass da einfach Feuerwehr ist und so notwendig, wenn die Leute irgendwie aus den Wohnungen rauskommen. Weil das muss man sich ja auch mal klar machen. Wir leben schon wieder in so einer selbstgefälligen, gemütlichen Realität. Da brennt zwar hier und da mal was, aber so, dass man jetzt so komplette Städte abbrennen oder so, davon hört man eigentlich eher selten. Aber das hat auch seinen Grund.
Das hat natürlich seinen Grund. Bauvorschriften kommen natürlich auch mit rein. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel auch gerade wieder ein Erdbeben vergleicht. In Schiele hat man gehört, sei irgendwie Richterskala 8,0 irgendwas gewesen. Uns ist verhältnismäßig wenig passiert in Schiele, wenn man das vergleicht mit dem letzten großen Erdbeben, was irgendwo in Asien war.
Oder Haiti jetzt gerade noch kurz vorher.
Oder Haiti vergleichbarer Stärke. Und da ist definitiv viel mehr passiert. Also das sind Bauvorschriften. Im Nachhinein natürlich auch Brandverhütungsvorschriften. Wenn wir jetzt zum Thema Feuer gehen, das schlägt mit rein. Und das hilft natürlich. Also das ist ein großer Teil, der damit dazugehört. Feuerwehr haben die in Haiti sicher auch und in Chile auch, klar. Aber man kann sich auch auf anderem Wege natürlich schon viel Arbeit ersparen.
Viel Mühen. Ja, wir haben ja schon vorhin den CCC erwähnt. Da gibt es ja auch so eine eigene freiwillige Feuerwehr, die sich da so herausgestellt hat. Man kann ja sagen, der Chaos Computer Club ist eigentlich der einzige Computer Club weltweit, der seinen eigenen Sanitätsdienst und Feuerwehr-Grundversorgung und Rettungsversorgung mit sich bringt. Dann ging das eigentlich los. Ich glaube, mit den Camps ging das los.
Das ging mit den Camps los, wenn ich hier mal nachschauke. Also grundsätzlich sprichst du das ZERT an. Chaos Emergency Response Team. Im Vergleich zu den Anbegriffen, ZERT-Begriffen, die es in der IT gibt, ist das jetzt erst mal nichts, was mit Security-Inzidenz zu tun hat. Zumindest nicht mit IT-Security. Das ZERT ist, also offiziell, wenn ich es richtig weiß, zum 19C3 er gegründet worden. Hat er aber dann auch den ersten wirklichen, so den Aufruf, Santa Sunny Fox sich gemeldet hat, ich könnte noch ein paar Leute brauchen, die mich einfach da unterstützen zum Thema Erste Hilfe oder so. Wenn ich es richtig weiß, war das damals Hacking at Large so eines der, was, dritte Camp in Holland, wenn ich es richtig zweite oder dritte Camp im Holland damals auch verhältnismäßig verregnet. Und da ging das mit dem Zert dann schon verhältnismäßig los, dass wir ein Zelt da hatten, dass immer Leute da saßen, wenn irgendjemand einen Pflaster brauchte, dass man auch mal rumgegangen ist, geguckt hat, ob irgendwo keine Nerds jetzt gerade ihr Zelt in Flammen stellen oder in Brand setzen.
Also was ich so erstaunlich daran finde, ist, dass sich das ausgerechnet in so einer Computerkultur geprägten Gruppe, so unglaublich viele Leute aus solchen Rettungsberufen oder Rettungsberufe, das ist ja nicht der Punkt, sondern es ist ein Hobby. So viele Leute sozusagen dem Sanitätsdienst oder eben auch der Feuerwehrtätigkeit da irgendwie geneigt sind. Gibt es da irgendwie so eine gute Erklärung dafür? Oder ist das jetzt einfach nur so ein Phänomen?
Eine wirkliche Erklärung dazu habe ich nicht, aber gerade im Vergleich ist das nicht der einzige Beweis dieses Phänomens. Wenn man jetzt im Usenet herumguckt, die entsprechenden Feuerwehrgruppen oder Rettungsdienstgruppen durchguckt, da tauchen dann immer die üblichen Verdächtigen auf, die auch irgendwie drei Fenster weiter in einer IT-Gruppe wildestens mitdiskutieren. Also da sind Schnittmengen da und die gibt es. Das ist bewiesen schon oft genug. Ich weiß nicht, woan es liegt.
Vielleicht liegt es einfach daran, dass es eben auch einfach eine ganze Menge auch mit Technik zu tun hat.
Kann daran sein, kann aber auch an dem klassischen Vergleich liegen, so irgendwie hier habe ich ein IT-Hobby, ich schaffe den ganzen Tag, ich kriege einfach nichts hin, ich frickele nur und da drüben kann ich auch was tun, was irgendwie ein Ergebnis hat.
So als Ausgleich.
Als Ausgleich natürlich auch.
Das ganze sinnlose Geklicke.
Den ganzen Tag gearbeitet, drei Zeilen rausgekriegt und erst kein Ergebnis und da drüben mache ich irgendwie was.
Da kann ich jetzt mal ein paar Eimer Wasser durch die Gegend schleppen. Ich habe den Verdacht, dass das auch so ein bisschen was mit diesem Technik-Ding zu tun hat. Gibt es denn eigentlich auch so eine katastrophale Männer-Frauen-Verteilung in Feuerwehrkreisen?
Katastrophal kann man es eigentlich schon nennen. Also ganz früher war es verhältnismäßig, wenn man jetzt einfach ein paar Jahre zurückgeht. Früher war man ja als Mann verpflichtet, zur Feuerwehr zu gehen. Oder man hat halt die sogenannte Brandschutzabgabe seiner Versicherung bezahlt. Also ich gehe zur Feuerwehr oder ich gehe eben nicht hin. Und dafür muss ich eine gewisse Brandschutzabgabe...
Ach, echt ernsthaft? Bis wann war denn das?
Wirklich?
Könnte man nachgucken. Also steht da drin sicher.
Ich habe noch nie eine Brandschutzabgabe bezahlt. Vor 15 Jahren? Vielleicht ist mir einfach abgezogen worden. Ich wusste es nicht mehr.
Ja, okay. Da war es auf jeden Fall... Da müssen wir noch einmal nachgucken. Da war es dann so, dass Männer ab 18 irgendwie einen gewissen Betrag zahlen mussten. Wenn sie nicht so frei weggegangen sind. Gut, da ist man halt dahin gegangen. Und dann kam die EU und dann kam so etwas, was sich Gleichberechtigung genannt hat. Da hat ein Mann geklagt. Wieso zahlen Frauen das nicht auch? Und irgendwie der Umkehrschluss war dann nicht, dass man gesagt hat, Frauen müssen jetzt auch zahlen, sondern gesagt hat, man lässt es. Und schon war irgendwie einer der Gründe, zur Feuerwehr zu gehen, es hat weggefallen. Und damit auch Personal.
Hat sich das deutlich geäußert?
Ich war damals noch nicht so weit, dass ich gesagt hätte, ich hätte es damals mitkriegen können. Aber ich denke, es hat sich sicher geäußert. Man hat sicher gemerkt, dass weniger Freiwillige da sind, die jetzt gehen wollen, dass man mehr tun muss, dass Leute in die Feuerwehr gehen.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass es keine Frauen gibt, den Eindruck habe ich nun gar nicht geworden.
Ich würde jetzt mal so grob sagen, dass wir im Moment bei 80-20, 4 zu 1.
Hast du gefühlt, das doppelt von dem, was die Computerszene üblicherweise stellen kann?
Ja, aber wenn ich es jetzt so mit dem Kongress vergleiche, der Kongress lag auch schon, ich würde es sogar mittlerweile mehr sagen, 70-30 schon.
Da fragst du 10 Leute und du kriegst 11 Antworten. Da es ja wegen des Datenschutzes keine entsprechenden Geschlechtererhebungen gibt, wissen wir das ja eigentlich auch gar nicht.
Genau, das sind alles rein optische Erhebungen.
Da ist ja dieser dobe Datenschutz. Da kriegt man gar keine richtigen Zahlen.
Und um noch mal auf Zert zurückzukommen, wer sich das angucken will, der Link taucht nachher sicher auf zert.ccc.de. Dort gibt es dann wer interessiert.
Das ist wirklich eine beeindruckende Gemeinde. Ich habe ja nun viel zu tun gehabt mit Organisationen von Camps usw. Und wenn man auf irgendwas zählen konnte, dann waren es einfach immer die Leute vom Zert. Und es hat mich immer extrem erstaunt, mit welcher Energie und Devotion da irgendwie alle auch dabei sind. Da herrscht irgendwie eine ganz andere Vorstellung von Disziplin.
Das wünscht man sich manchmal bei den gemeinen Nerds ja.
Nee, aber es ist natürlich so, dass man sich solche autark agierenden Gruppen nur wünschen kann. So, Club hat also eine Feuerwehr. Die Gesellschaft hat eine Feuerwehr, eine Freiwillige und eine Berufsfeuerwehr. Berufsfeuerwehr ab einer bestimmten Gemeindegröße. Aber wir haben festgehalten, freiwillige Feuerwehr macht einfach eine ganze Menge aus. Gut, jetzt hast du ja gesagt, man kommt da irgendwie hin so als Jugendlicher. Was kriegt man denn dann? Also, wie wird man denn da angenommen? Was durchläuft man denn in dem Moment, wenn man da auftaucht? Soll man da auf den Platz gestellt und dann erstmal nass gespritzt?
Nein. Zum Beispiel? Nein, keine Rituale, wie man jetzt wieder laufend hört, dass Rituale auftauchen bei der Bundeswehr oder so was. Die zwar jeder schon wusste, kannte, nur anscheinend die Medien nicht. Nein, also wenn bei uns zum Beispiel ein Jugendlicher neu dazukommt, dann darf er sich das irgendwie einen Abend anschauen, ein, zwei, drei Abende. Und irgendwann kriegt er halt dann auch mal, da wir schließlich in Deutschland sind, einen Zettel mit für seine Eltern, die sie dann bitte ausfüllen sollten. Name, Adresse des Arztes, ob irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen bestehen.
Ja gut, du hast ja gesagt, es gibt da auch richtig eine Jugendausbildung, die dann irgendwie so geboten wird. Und da kann man irgendwie kostenlos daran teilnehmen.
Genau, da kann man natürlich kostenlos daran teilnehmen. Die lernen Feuerwehrtechnik, Abläufe in der Feuerwehr natürlich, also kriegen schon wirklich eine grundlegende Ausbildung. Was haben wir für Fahrzeuge, die kriegen eine Ausrüstung, kriegen Jacke, Helm, Handschuhe, Stiefel, kriegen sie auch alles. Und können dann sehen, was die Aktiven machen, kriegen das von aktiven Feuerwehrleuten beigebracht, die sie zusätzlich noch auf sich nehmen, Jugendliche auszubilden dort.
Also auch Freiwillige?
Genau, dasselbe auch, wie der Freiwillige, die auch noch gesagt haben, okay, ich hab Interesse daran, irgendwelche Jugendlichen zwischen 10 und 18, 12 und 18, je nach Ort, ab wann sie die aufnehmen, auszubilden, die Spaß dran haben und es dann denen versuchen, möglichst gut beizubringen und sie auch bei der Stange zu halten. Natürlich macht man dann auch mal noch Sachen außerhalb des Feuerwehrtums, man geht irgendwie mit denen mal Fußball spielen, irgendwelche Besichtigungen, man geht mal ins Freibad, macht irgendwelche Zeltlager, irgendwelche Camps oder so, da man mit Feuerwehr allein, die dann auch nicht wirklich dran halten kann. Und auch, weil jetzt ein Jugendlicher, der jetzt, ich sag jetzt mal, mit zehn in die Jugendfeuerwehr eintritt, irgendwann mit 16 kommt nachher das Problem auf, dass er eine Ausbildung macht und weniger Zeit hat, falls er eine Ausbildung macht, aber dass er sich dann auch irgendwann sagt, hör mal zu, ich war jetzt hier schon sechs Jahre und ich mach jetzt irgendwie das sechste Jahr dasselbe. Also müssen wir natürlich gucken, dass wir Abwechslung reinkriegen und dass man auch einfach, wenn möglich, wenn man so viele hart Altersgruppen bildet und dann halt den Altersgruppen spezifisch ausbildet und man halt mit den Älteren auch schon eher vielleicht so richtig sozusagen die Einsätze macht, um die auch wirklich noch dran zu halten.
Aber man wird jetzt nicht gleich beim ersten Tag an den Brandherd geschickt, sondern...
Nein, also...
Da kommt dann erstmal ein bisschen Basis.
Auflagen gibt es eh genug dafür. Wir dürften mit den Jugendlichen, wir dürften sie nicht auf Leitern jagen, wir dürften ihnen keinen Strahlrohr in die Hand geben, zumindest, wenn es ganz was Wasser drauf hat. Gibt einfach zum Schutz der Jugendlichen gewisse Vorgaben. Sie dürfen nicht an Motorsägen dran, sodass man natürlich in gewissen Rahmen eingeschränkt ist. Aber man kriegt das hin und kann genug mit denen machen. Ein Feuer in dem Sinn, die werden nicht in ein Feuer geschickt. Man löscht vielleicht, man zündet irgendwo einen kleinen Stapel Holz, den sie dann löschen können, damit sie auch mal ein Feuer sehen oder so. Aber jetzt werden sie nicht in Feuer reingeschickt. Also nein, das kommt dann erst später, wenn man irgendwie aktiv ist. Und auch mal andere Sachen gelernt hat.
Und wie viel muss man da lernen, bevor es irgendwie richtig lustig wird? Dass man mal in so einem Einsatz teilnehmen kann? Muss man dann auch schon eine Ausbildung abschließen?
Genau, also irgendwie, jetzt haben wir mal rein eine Jugendfeuerwehr. Dann darf man dann mit, muss ich lügen, unter gewissen Voraussetzungen mit 17 darf man seinen Grundausbildungslehrgang machen. Das ist dann so der erste größere Lehrgang, den man macht. Und der größte auch, das sind, mittlerweile sind es, wenn ich es richtig weiß, 60 Stunden. Das sind also sechs, sieben Wochen lang zwei Abende plus jeweils ein ganzer Samstag Ausbildung. Da kriegt man dann wirklich einmal den ganzen Wesen oder die ganze Art Aufgaben der Feuerwehr, die ganzen Tätigkeiten, die man so im Laufe seines Feuerwehrlebens machen muss, als Feuerwehrmann einmal beigebracht. Wie lösche ich, wie gehe ich mit der Motorsäge um? Was haben wir auf den Fahrzeugen drauf? Wie sichere ich eine Einsatzstelle ab? Was kriegen die dort alles beigebracht? Im zweiten Schritt kommt dann zusätzlich zu dieser Ausbildung noch Druckmann-2-Ausbildung sozusagen, das heißt dann nochmal ein Jahr lang dieselbe Ausbildung inhaltlich dann nochmal vor Ort.
Also mit anderen Worten, man kommt da eigentlich auch relativ schnell ans Ziel. Ich meine 60 Stunden, das ist ja jetzt nicht so viel.
Genau.
Also wenn man da hingeht und weiß, ich bleib da jetzt einfach mal 3 Monate dran an dem ganzen Sport, dann weiß man auch schon richtig was.
Genau, dann kriegt man schon einiges mitgebracht. Auch hier will natürlich wieder, wer schon in der Jugendfahrwehr war, wird sich bei dieser Grundausbildung sehr leicht tun, weil er das hoffentlich alles schon mal gehört hat. Danach geht es dann ganz schnell weiter. Man kriegt natürlich noch eine Funkausbildung verpasst, dass man mit den Funkgeräten, die man so hat, auch umgehen kann. Und direkt danach sollte dann gleich noch eine Ausbildung zum Atemschutzgeräteträger folgen, dass man den Kameraden, die Person dann auch verwenden kann, um mit in den Einsatz in ein brennendes Objekt oder zumindest, wenn es irgendwo raucht, auch hin mitzunehmen. Und dort ihn dann verwenden kann. Und das ist dann so bis zum Atemschutzgeräteträger eigentlich das, was eigentlich jeder Feuerwehrmann im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten kommt, natürlich auch eine gesundheitliche Überprüfung dazu, ob man die Leistung auch bringen kann, so ein Gerät zu tragen, auch dazu. Und eigentlich sollte man jeden Feuerwehrmann so weit bringen.
So, was ist man dann, wenn man so eine Ausbildung abgeschlossen hat?
Dann ist man erst mal Feuerwehrmann.
Dann ist man Feuerwehrmann.
Genau.
So heißt das dann auch.
Genau. Das ist allerdings Ländersache. Das kann in anderen Ländern wieder anders heißen, in anderen Bundesländern leider.
Feuerwehrmann, Feuerwehrfrau?
Das heißt, das bleibt noch. Also vorher ist man irgendwie Feuerwehrmann-Anwärter, dann wird man irgendwann per Handschlag vom Kommando übernommen. Dann heißt es dann Feuerwehrmann.
Ich meine, wenn man jetzt eine Frau ist, heißt man dann auch Feuerwehrmann?
Heißt Feuerwehrfrau. Genau, ist mittlerweile angepasst worden.
Feuerwehrfrau. Gut. Und dann passiert eigentlich erst mal gar nichts, weil man ist ja nur freiwillig und hat ja eigentlich gar nichts zu tun.
Dann hofft man, mal ganz frech gesagt, hofft man auf Einsätze, man macht eine Übung.
Hoffentlich brennt mal was.
Das ist halt heutzutage.
Aber es ist ja das mit dem Brennen, das liegt natürlich auch im Namen, aber es ist ja beileibe nicht so, dass jetzt die Einsatzrealität der Feuerwehr ausschließlich aus dem Löschen von Bränden bestehen würde, oder?
Nein, im Gegenteil. Ich würde sogar sagen, dass es mittlerweile, zumindest jetzt bei uns im Ort, 20 Prozent, 10 Prozent, dass wirklich noch Brände sind.
Was sind denn so die Fälle, die normalerweise so auftreten?
Die Fälle, die im Normalfass aufreden, ich gehe jetzt mal auf die Einsatzliste sozusagen vom letzten Jahr zurück. Gut, es ging schon los, 8.1., ein Vollbrand. Gut, da hat es dann wirklich mal in einem Nachbarort gebrannt. Wir mussten hin zur Unterstützung.
Vollbrand.
Ein Vollbrand, ein sogenanntes. Das heißt, ein Haus steht voll im Brand. Also nicht nur der Dachstuhl oben.
Das brennt.
Das brennt auch mal noch irgendwo aus dem Fenster raus, ein paar Stockwerke tiefer, genau.
Richtig große Scheiße.
Dann haben wir hier irgendwie eine Menschenrettung aus dem Rhein.
Da ist einer in Fluss gefallen.
Genau. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob da irgendjemand genau in Fluss gefallen war.
Aber das ist ja auch so eine klassische Tätigkeit. Also Rettung ist ja eigentlich auch eigentlich, kann man sagen, das ist die Hauptaufgabe eigentlich.
Letztendlich kann man alles unter den Oberbegriff retten.
Weil das ist ja auch 112, also der Notruf, den man als irgendwie immer als Feuerwehrruf im Kopf hat, ist ja tatsächlich der, wie heißt das korrekt?
Notruf, Rettungsruf, Notruf, Notruffeuerwehr.
Und nicht 110?
Nein, also, sagen wir so, einfacher ist es, die 110 erstmal festzulegen, da landet man wirklich bei der Polizei.
Genau.
So, bei 112 landet man meistens auf irgendeiner sogenannten Leitstelle. Wenn das jetzt eine integrierte Leitstelle ist, dann sitzt dort ein Mitarbeiter von entweder Feuerwehr oder Rettungsdienst, der dann aber beides managen kann. Und dem kann man dann einfach sagen, okay, ich hab hier eine Schnittwunde, ich brauch irgendjemand. Oder bei uns brennt es, ich brauch jemand, der kümmert sich darum, der managt es dann. Wenn man jetzt dagegen bei der Polizei rufen würde, entweder die nehmen es auf, geben es weiter oder sagen, okay, ich muss sie aber verbinden und stellen dich dann durch rüber. Okay, also 112 ist schon das Richtige.
Genau, 112 ist Rettungsruf, gut. Und da musste dir jemand aus dem Fluss fischen?
Genau, da hieß es dann, jemand ist reingetrieben. Das heißt, wir haben unser Boot genommen, das Boot ins Wasser geworfen.
So ein Schlauchboot?
Nö, das ist schon festes.
Das habt ihr ins Wasser geworfen?
Das haben wir an ein Fahrzeug angehängt, runtergefahren, ans Wasser, ins Zuwasser gelassen, genau. Das liegt also nur im Sommer, haben wir das fest im Wasser, was uns dann natürlich auch ca. eine Viertelstunde spart. Und dann haben wir dann...
Den habt ihr aber noch gerettet bekommen? Okay, pade.
So, dann geht's weiter, gut, noch mal ein Feuer. Abwasser, was in Wohngebäude drückt. Das war natürlich eher ein etwas nieserer Einsatz.
Abwasser.
Abwasser, genau, und zwar genau das, was du dir da vorstellst. Und das wird dann gleich mal zur Feuerwehr-Aufgabe.
Gehört dazu.
Wenn es ein bisschen weniger ist, könnte man natürlich noch sagen, ist nicht unser Job, holen sie irgendwie einen Wasserklemmner oder so was, der ihnen da weiterhilft. Aber ab einer gewissen Menge haben wir einfach, dass die Hardware dafür, sprich pumpen, in entsprechendem Format, um dort auch weiterhelfen zu können.
Inwieweit ist denn die Feuerwehr eigentlich zur Hilfe verpflichtet? Also ich meine gerade jetzt so was wie mein Keller läuft voll Wasser, da könnte man halt sagen, ja, dumm gelaufen, dann kübel mal ordentlich. Wo ist denn da so die, der Schnittpunkt zwischen irgendwie persönlich in einen Scheißetopf gefasst bis hin zu hier liegt ein Problem vor, wo die Gesellschaft aushelfen muss oder ist das einfach nur so, da wird man, wenn man halt gerufen wird, dann muss man das auch bezahlen oder wie läuft das?
Von bezahlen kommen wir noch dazu. Das Ganze regelt jeweils im Land, also es ist eine Ländersache auch wieder, das Feuerwehrgesetz. Und dort steht letztendlich auch drin, wann ein Einsatz der Feuerwehr einfach bezahlt werden muss. Und da läuft sowas dann einfach letztendlich hinaus. Wenn man sagt, hier Abwasser drückt ins Wohngebäude, klar, wir haben ihm geholfen, aber der hat letztendlich auch eine Rechnung dafür gekriegt. Gerätestunden, Mannstunden, je nachdem sogar Verdienstausfall.
Wobei es ja jetzt nicht unbedingt heißt, dass es seine Schuld war.
Abwasser drückt nicht ins Wohngebäude.
Klingt jetzt ein bisschen wie ein Problem der Kanalisation.
Er kriegt erst mal die Rechnung, und ob er es dann zahlt, ist halt seiner Versicherung. Aber es ist einfach die Frage, ob wirklich jetzt eine Rechnung gestellt wird von der Feuerwehr oder nicht. Im Normalfall bei Bränden, klassisch, wird keine Rechnung gestellt. Es sei denn, man hat irgendwie Sonderlöschmittel, Schaum, irgendwas in bestimmten Mengen gebraucht, dann wird da drüber natürlich eine Rechnung geschrieben. Aber so klassisch Brand, keine Rechnung. Wenn es auch um Menschenrettung geht, keine Rechnung. Aber jetzt einen Verkehrsunfall, zum Beispiel ein simpler Verkehrsunfall, wo man dann irgendwie Öl abschreuen musste oder jemanden raus retten, aber es war keine Menschenrettung. Oder ein Fahrzeug ist irgendwann abgestürzt, wir müssen das einfach hochziehen, gibt es dafür eine Rechnung, weil das keine Pflichtaufgabe der Feuerwehr ist, sondern eine sogenannte Kann-Aufgabe. Und das ist auch einfach die Unterscheidung. Wasser im Keller hätte auch jemand anders machen können. Wir waren nicht verpflichtet, also gibt es eine Rechnung dafür.
Und was kann nur die Feuerwehr?
Brände löschen. Also kann, ach so, das war Pflicht. Was kann die Feuerwehr? Wir können jemanden Wasser im Keller auspumpen, wir können die Katze vom Baumwein retten als Klassiker.
Hattet ihr das auch schon? Wirklich? Da rufen Leute die Feuerwehr an, um eine Katze vom Baum zu retten.
Weil die Katze da oben auf dem Baumwein, genau. Also ich sag jetzt mal, in einer klassischen Dorfsituation wäre man zum Nachbarn gegangen, hätte die große Leiter geholt.
Aber diese Nachbarschaftssituation gibt es nicht mehr.
Aber wenn das dann nicht mehr irgendwie gibt, diese Nachbarschaftshilfe, weil das jetzt nicht die Gemeinde ist, wo jetzt irgendwie jemanden kennt, dann muss halt die Feuerwehr ran und das arme Kätzchen da vom Baum runterholen.
Die Feuerwehr, dein Freund und Helfer. Das minzt man eigentlich in der Regel immer auf die Polizei, diesen Spruch. Aber das trifft ja für die Feuerwehr nicht weniger zu.
Genau.
Okay, sag nochmal ein paar von deinen Einsätzen. Das ist eigentlich eine schöne Liste, an der man mal ein bisschen die Realität anklappern kann.
Genau. Türöffnung für den Rettungsdienst. Das heißt, irgendjemand hat einen Rettungsdienst gerufen. Und der Rettungsdienst kam dann halt dort an und hat aber eine verschlossene Tür vorgefunden. Ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht sagen, ob die jetzt einfach nicht kräftig genug waren, um die Tür einfach mal aufzutreten. Oder ob man einfach gesagt hat, grundsätzlich okay, Tür ist verschlossen, wir alarmieren die Feuerwehr einfach mit, dass die uns die Tür aufmacht. Wenn ich es richtig weiß, haben wir dann einen Schreiner sogar dabei, der dann verhältnismäßig gut oder mit möglichst wenig Schaden die Tür einfach aufgemacht hat.
Aber ihr kriegt alles auf?
Zur Not mit etwas mehr Werkzeug, aber man kriegt sie dann im Normalfall auf. Das war jetzt kein wirklich großer Einsatz. Da haben also dann zwei Leute vorn gereicht, die das dann gemacht haben.
Und noch was Größeres am Start?
Was hätten wir hier? Größer ist es nicht. Klingt nur bedeutend, eine Hubschrauberlandung. Das, was im Normalfall dann einfach heißt, dass wir ein Gelände für einen Hubschrauber einfach abgesichert und ausgeleuchtet haben, dass der dann dort aus irgendeinem Grund, weil er irgendwo hin musste, landen konnte.
Ja, irgendjemand muss das ja auch machen.
Was haben wir denn hier? Ein Fahrzeugbrand, klassisch. Fahrzeug auf der Autobahn hat auf einmal angefangen zu brennen. Gut, dann muss die Feuerwehr hin. Wir hatten es davon, brennen ist eine Pflichtaufgabe. Ist dann einfach unser Job.
Was man immer wieder raus hört, ist, also bei jedem dieser Einsätze, ist eigentlich immer eine ganze Menge Equipment am Start. Man muss irgendwie Licht haben, man muss ein Boot haben, man muss Zangen oder Knüppel oder sonstiges Entsperrgerät haben, Sachen heben und so weiter. Dieser ganze Ausrüstungsklimbim, das ist doch bestimmt auch Nerd Heaven, oder? Also so eine Ausrüstungshalle der Feuerwehr. Was hält denn so eine Feuerwehr üblicherweise alles vor?
Was hält eine Feuerwehr vor? Wenn ich es jetzt mit meiner Feuerwehr vergleiche.
Wie groß ist eure Feuerwehr? Mitglieder?
250, 200?
Ist das groß?
Nein, also es ist eine Gemeinde mit 8000 Einwohnern. Oder 150 Mitglieder. In etwa.
Zu 8000 Einwohnern, das ist ja schon ein ganz gutes Verhältnis.
Genau, liegt unter anderem daran, dass es eine sehr ländliche Gegend ist. Einige Abteilungen, die halt auf Dörfern sind. Da funktioniert es im Normalfall auch ein bisschen besser. Die einen gehen in den Musikverein, die anderen gehen zur Feuerwehr. Das ist natürlich ein anderer Zusammenhalt, als es jetzt sein kann in städtischen Gegenden.
Und ihr habt ein Feuerwehrgebäude, ihr habt Löschzüge.
Genau, wir haben ein Feuerwehrgebäude, also sozusagen im Kernort, in der Stadt selber eins. Da stehen jetzt, kurz durchgesetzt, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Fahrzeuge drin. Plus dann auf den einzelnen Abteilungen jeweils noch ein Fahrzeug.
Was sind das dann für Fahrzeuge?
Im Normalfall, wenn man jetzt die Abteilung durchgeht, ist das ein Fahrzeug. Hören wir ganz einfach an, 4 Räder, das ist rot. Es hat mit viel Glück Wasser dabei. Das haben die Neueren erst. Früher hat man einfach kein Wasser mitgeführt auf den Fahrzeugen.
Generell nicht.
Man hat einfach keins dabei gehabt, weil einfach der Platz nicht da war. Man muss dann halt gucken, dass man aus dem Hydranten-Netz, aus dem öffentlichen Wasser holt oder aus irgendeinem Bach-Fluss-See.
Wenn es ums Löschen geht. Aber jetzt in zunehmendem Maße haben die auch Wasser an Bord.
Genau, die Neueren-Fahrzeuge, man kann kein neues Fahrzeug mehr, kein Lösch-Fahrzeug mehr, fester Begriff, mehr kaufen. Man kriegt keinen Zuschuss mehr, wenn man nicht eins nimmt, was Wasser an Bord hat.
Aber das ist dann auch nicht so viel Wasser?
Naja, 2.500 Liter im Durchschnitt. Normales Lösch-Fahrzeug.
Und der Hintergrund ist, dass man immer schon mal gerüstet sein will für den ersten Einsatz?
Dass man für die ersten paar Minuten einfach, dass keiner sich darum kümmern muss, Wasser zu holen, was vielleicht auch wieder zwei, drei Minuten braucht, sondern dass man einfach schon mal Wasser hat und schon mal loslegen kann.
Und im Idealfall, in der Zeit, wo man das dann verbraucht hat, schon einen anderen Anschluss gelegt hat und es einfach weitergeht?
Im Idealfall braucht man es gar nicht erst auf oder man hat bis dahin natürlich für Nachschub gesorgt.
Und wie viele Löschfahrzeuge habt ihr?
Wie viele Lösch? Also ich sag dir jetzt einfach mal vom Stützpunkt aus, da haben wir sozusagen zwei Löschfahrzeuge stehen.
Und das sind jetzt so diese klassischen Leiterwagen?
Das ist ein klassisches, wie du sagst, Fahrzeug, auf dem ein unbedarfter Leiter oben draufsieht, mindestens eine. Genau, da ist ein Feuerwehrauto vorbeigefahren. Das war, weiss ich, welches war es denn? Ja, es war rot und es hat eine Leiter drauf gehabt. Okay, da sind wir noch nicht viel weiter. Aber die Unterscheidung ist natürlich...
Na, sag mal, welche Kategorien ihr da so aufruft. Deswegen frage ich ja auch. Also ein Fahrzeug.
Genau, es kann ein simples Löschfahrzeug sein. Es kann aber auch ein Tanklöschfahrzeug sein. Die Unterscheidung ist mittlerweile verhältnismäßig fließend, weil auch neuere Löschfahrzeuge einen Tank dabei haben, auch Wasser dabei haben. Sie sind nur etwas in der Nutzung etwas breiter gefächert. Da kann ein bisschen mehr Material dabei sein. Sie sind im Normalfall auch mit neun Leuten besetzt, während aus der Kategorie ein Tanklöschfahrzeug im Normalfall nur sechs Leute dabei hat.
Okay.
Da man einfach mehr auf das Löschen setzt und dort einfach nur die sechs bräuchte.
Und kommen diese Löschfahrzeuge auch nur zum Löschen zum Einsatz?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Also ein klassisches Löschfahrzeug, wenn ich jetzt bei uns gucke, so ein LF 16. 16 heißt in dem Fall auch nur die Pumpenleistung von der fest eingebauten Pumpe, die da drin ist. Das sind 1.600 Liter Wasser in der Minute. Bei einem bestimmten Nenndruck, also das merkt man, dass da irgendwelche Techniker dran waren oder irgendwelche Ingenieure, die das dann genau festgelegt haben, bei dem Druck diese Fördermenge. Da sind neun Leute drauf. Und mit dem Fahrzeug kann ich jetzt schon verhältnismäßig alles machen, was bei uns im Normalfass so dran kommt. Sonderzubehör hab ich dann einfach vielleicht nicht drauf. Wenn es jetzt um Ölspuren geht, dann müsste ich noch irgendwo aus dem Regal noch ein, zwei, drei Säcke Ölbindemittel mitnehmen. Ich hab natürlich, wenn es um ein Hochhaus geht, keine große Leiter dabei. Also eine sogenannte Drehleiter. Die hab ich dann natürlich nicht mit. Aber auch hier hab ich jetzt beim Rysch-Fahrzeug zwei Leitern drauf, mit denen ich zumindest schon mal bis in etwa acht bis zehn Meter schon mal Dinge tun kann. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber es ist schon so eine, wie man sich das so vorstellt. Ich versuch jetzt hier erstmal meine alten Kinderträume einzufangen. So sieht auch eine Feuerwehr aus, mal ehrlich. Rot, lang, Leiter drauf, gehört einfach dazu.
Genau, also im Normalfall hab ich eine sogenannte Schiebleiter drauf. Die ist jetzt 8 Meter lang. Ah nein, also normalerweise hab ich eine Steckleiter drauf auf so einem Fahrzeug. Die hab ich zumindest auf jedem Fahrzeug, auch auf Tanklöschfahrzeugen. Die ist 8,40 Meter lang und ich kann mit der Arbeitshöhe 7,20 Meter. Das heißt, bis 7,20 Meter, was im Normalfall, also ich sag jetzt mal hier im Süden, dann doch mal eher drei Stockwerke sind. In Berlin sind es dann vielleicht eher nur zwei mit Altbauten. Ich dann zumindest mal tätig werden kann und noch irgendwo reingehen kann. Wenn ich jetzt die Leiter klassisch verwende, um irgendwo hochzusteigen, man kann natürlich auch noch viele andere Sachen damit machen.
Sachen überbrücken oder so?
Sachen überbrücken, irgendwo runtergehen.
Und Steckleiter heißt das wirklich so, dass einer Teil aufs andere Teil gesteckt wird?
Das sind im Normalfall vier Teile, die dann zusammengesteckt werden.
Vier Stück.
Die dann je nach Fahrzeug zwei und zwei draufliegen, zwei schon zusammen und dann jeweils zwei. Die größere Variante ist dann eine sogenannte Schiebleiter drauf zu haben. Die ist schon komplett. Die muss aber wie ein Flaschenzug auseinandergezogen werden. Damit komme ich dann allerdings auch schon auf zwölf Meter. Das ist dann schon mal ein bisschen Unterschied wieder. Das macht auch im Normalfall den Unterschied zwischen einem größeren Löschfahrzeug und einem Tanklöschfahrzeug aus, weil diese Schiebleiter nur auf einem großen Löschfahrzeug drauf ist.
Weil es einfach eine aufwendige Konstruktion ist?
Genau, weil auch der Platz einfach da sein muss. Muss ja schließlich mitgebracht werden.
Und was ist noch so drauf auf so einem Teil? Also was ist so, wenn ich so einen Löschfahrzeug jetzt einfach ohne weiteres zu tun aus der Halle fahre? Was habe ich dann alles dabei?
Was hast du dabei? Also fang mal an, du hast 2500 Liter Wasser dabei. Die sind irgendwo für dich nicht sichtbar untergebracht. Der Tank ist einfach in der Fahrzeugmitte. So, direkt hinten dran, direkt fest angeschlossen, ist einfach die passende sogenannte Feuerlöschkreiselpumpe, was dann auch schon aussagt, wie sie betrieben wird.
Also das ist das Ding, was das Wasser pumpt?
Genau. Was fest dran montiert ist, fest am Tank hängt und einfach dafür sorgt, dass das Wasser dann auch...
Und wenn du sagst Wasser, dann reden wir auch wirklich nur von Wasser.
Ganz normales Leitungswasser. Wird auch aus dem normalen Hydranten irgendwo gefüllt. Das ist, sagen wir mal, das ist Trinkwasser. In diesem Tank ist definiert immer Trinkwasser drin. Der wird nicht aus dem Rhein oder aus irgendeinem anderen Fluss aus einem Bach aufgefüllt. Weil auch die Feuerwehr im Katastrophenfall natürlich auch Wasser ausliefern müsste, Trinkwasser, wenn irgendwo Wassermangel herrscht.
Ah, dass man es halt auch einfach als Trinkwasser...
Genau, dass man den Tank dann nicht erst extra noch mal desinfizieren und reinigen muss.
Stimmt.
Das heißt, auch wenn jetzt wirklich Wasser entnommen wird, aus einem Fluss zum Löschen, wird er zwar durch die Pumpe laufen, aber nie über den Tank. Dass der Tank einfach nicht verunreinigt wird.
Okay. Und dann kann man das irgendwie mit 16.000 Liter pro Minute raushauen?
Genau, was bei 2.500 Litern gleich mal heißt, nach anderthalb Minuten, ist fertig.
Okay. Das macht schon ordentlich Wumms.
Genau. Wenn du es wegkriegst.
Okay, aber Wasser ist ja jetzt nicht das Einzige, was man dabei hat. Also auf jeden Fall brauchen wir auch erstmal wahrscheinlich einen Satz Schläuche.
Genau. Unsere Schläuche ist natürlich drauf, die entsprechenden Mittel zur Wasserförderung, zur Wasserabgabe, sprich, wir haben Schläuche drauf, wir haben noch irgendwelches Material dazwischen, um das vielleicht zu verteilen.
C-Schläuche oder sowas?
Genau. Das sind einfach die Kategorien vom Durchmesser, was einfach die Größe ausmacht und letztendlich auch ausmacht, wie viel Wasser ich durchkriege. A sind die größten, B-, C geht bis D runter, E gibt es nachher nicht mehr.
Und will man nicht immer irgendwie den größten haben eigentlich?
Mittlerweile nicht mehr, weil die Versicherungen ganz schön einfach dahinter sind. Also mit A-Schläuchen löscht man im Normalfall sowieso nicht. Klassiker ist jetzt, also im Normalfall nimmt man C-Schlauch zum Löschen.
Der A-Schlauch ist sozusagen nur die...
Zum Wasser ansaugen im Normalfall.
Okay. Oder überhaupt zum Verteilen erst mal.
Meistens nur zum Ansaugen und das sind dann auch andere Schläuche, die sind armiert. Das, wenn ich da einen Unterdruck drauf gebe, dass der Schlauch nicht einfach irgendwie sofort in sich zusammenfällt. Dann ist ein Eisen drin, dass die armiert bleiben, dass die auch den Unterdruck bis an das Wasser letztendlich weitergeben können, dass es auch angesaugt wird.
Ah, verstehe. Sonst saugt man den Schlauch zu.
Genau, reine Physikgeschichte.
Also ein Saugschlauch sozusagen.
Ein Saugschlauch, heißt genau auch so. Genau, und dann habe ich einfach die verschiedenen Größen. Im Normalfall so eine Wasserabgabe, zum Löschen im Normalfall einen klassischen P-Schlauch. So einen klassischen C-Schlauch vorne dran. Mit einem sogenannten Strahlrohr vorne dran, was mir dann hilft, das Wasser zu dosieren, auch das Wasser abzustellen und vielleicht sogar auch noch den Wasserstrahl entsprechend gewünscht einzustellen. Direkten Stahl geradeaus oder vielleicht was zum Eigenschutz, weit aufgestellt.
Eigenschutz, was man so Feuer vor der Nase hat.
Genau, dass ich irgendwie bis auf einen Meter an Feuer ran kann und einfach von der Hitze, von dem Feuer nichts abkriege. Und dann kann man selber auch noch ein bisschen löschen.
Das heißt, der macht so einen Sprühnebel und pumpt aber trotzdem auch noch was nach vorne.
Genau, das sind dann, früher hatten wir die nicht. Früher hatten wir ein ganz normales sogenanntes Mehrzweckstrahlrohr, was dem Namen einfach nicht gerecht wird. Der Mehrzweck war damals, dass man einfach unterscheiden konnte in einen Sprühstrahl oder einen Vollstrahl. Mittlerweile mit den holzigen, sogenannten Hohlstrahlrohren kann man einfach viel mehr machen. Man kann die Wassermengen auch direkt regulieren in Litern pro Minute. Dass man auch nicht immer mit dem Ganzen, was jetzt der Schlauch liefert, irgendwie spritzen muss. Und auch sagt, okay, ich bin hier in einem Gebäude. Ich muss jetzt nicht auf ein kleines Feuerchen, auf irgendeiner Couch einfach gleich mit 120 Litern pro Minute draufhauen. Sondern ich kann auch sagen, okay, 50 Liter die Minute reichen. Das Wasser muss jetzt nicht drei Stockwerke weiter unten auch noch aus dem Gebäude wieder rauslaufen. Da sind auch die Versicherungen natürlich hinterher. Wenn es dann heißt, ja, ihr habt einen Brandschaden von 20.000 Euro verhindert, aber ihr habt 50.000 Euro Wasserschaden irgendwie angerichtet, dann wären die Versicherungen etwas zickig.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht so das Damoklessperd, was man die ganze Zeit so im Nacken spürt, oder?
Nicht im Nacken, aber es gehört einfach dazu mittlerweile. Nicht einfach nur Wasser draufhauen, sondern vielleicht auch mal den Kopf einschalten.
Was sind denn da so für Kontrolls an dieser, wie heißt das genannt, die Spritztüter?
Strahlrohr? Hohlstrahlrohr. Mittlerweile ist das von der Halterung auch, also im Griff sage ich jetzt mal, nicht wie an einer Pistole, aber sozusagen gerade spritzen wir das Wasser raus, und du hast senkrecht dazu den Griff zum Festhalten. Das heißt, man kann es auch auf den Arm aufstützen. Der Rückstoß von dem Wasser wird ein bisschen abgegriffen, da der im Normalfall der Rückstoß würde dir das Strahlrohr nach oben drücken. Das kannst du so mittlerweile greifen, und da ist oben drauf ein großer Querhebel, an dem du es öffnen und schließen kannst. Und meistens vorne dann kombiniert in zwei Ringen einmal die Einstellung, welchen Wasserstrahl du gerne hättest, mehr geradeaus, mehr gerichtet, mehr zum Eigenschutz, mehr sprühend und einfach noch ein zusätzlicher Ring, um die Wassermenge zu regulieren. Einfach drei Kontrollen sozusagen dran, die aber alle mit einer Hand bedient werden.
Und die andere hält die ganze Zeit?
Die andere muss das Ding halten. Die hat damit genug zu tun.
Und dann was am Arsch?
Genau.
Und das ist sozusagen das Lösch-Equipment im Wesentlichen?
Das ist sozusagen das primäre Lösch-Equipment, was man so im Normalfall hat.
Was ist noch auf dem Bus?
Was haben wir noch auf dem Fahrzeug drauf? Fangen wir mal von vorne an. Alles Mögliche, das einfachste, alles Mögliche Material, um uns selber eine Einsatzstelle abzusichern. Pylonen, Blinklichter, Warn-Dreiecke, klassisch. Dann haben wir drauf, man kann mal bei der Technik, wir haben drauf ein sogenanntes Hydraulikaggregat. Das heißt, Aggregat, was uns irgendwie für bestimmte Geräte einen Hydraulikdruck von, sagen wir mal, 200 Bar aufbaut, um damit andere Geräte zu bedienen zu können.
Also einen Wasserdruck erzeugen?
Nein, Öl in dem Fall.
Ach so, okay.
Also Hydraulikflüssigkeit natürlich. Einen Öldruck erzeugen, um andere Geräte dort anzuschließen.
Und was für Geräte sind das?
Genau, die Geräte, das könnte sein ein sogenannter Hydraulikstempel. Das ist einfach ein, wie man es jetzt an einem Baggerfond dran kennt. Ein Bagger hat überall Hydraulikstempel, um den Baggerarm aufzuklappen, einzuklappen, die Schaufel zu klappen, mit der Schaufel zu schaufeln.
Ach so, diese teleskopartigen Hebel- und Zug-Elemente.
Genau.
Stempel nennt man das.
Das nennt man Stempel. Kann ich zum Beispiel einsetzen, um eine Tür aufzumachen. Nicht, wenn ich schon eine Öffnung habe, um es reinzusetzen und dann die Öffnung zu erweitern.
Verstehe, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Dafür. Das ist die eine Variante, dann könnte ich sozusagen eine Hydraulik-Schere drauf haben.
Um was aufzuschneiden?
Um was aufzuschneiden, um zum Beispiel bei einem Fahrzeug zu sagen, okay, ich will jetzt hier diese Schwelle hier unten in der Tür, nachdem ich die Tür geöffnet habe, in der Schwelle unten einen Schnitt reinmachen, um das Fahrzeug abknicken zu können. Diese Hydraulik-Schere vorne ans Aggregat rangehängt, Druck drauf gegeben, durchgeschnitten.
Das Ding macht bestimmt ganz ordentlich Schnitt.
Genau. Wird heutzutage immer schwerer. Liegt an den Fahrzeugen, dass die immer besser werden. Die sogenannte passive Sicherheitstechnik an den Fahrzeugen. Es ist ein gegenseitiges Aufrüsten. Man braucht dann natürlich auch wieder stärkere Geräte, um durch die Autos letztendlich auch wieder anzukommen, an die eingeklemmten Personen zum Beispiel.
Macht sich das echt so deutlich?
Ja, man braucht mittlerweile dann doch die etwas größeren Geräte, die natürlich im Umkehrschluss leider wieder schwerer werden. Das heißt, das Arbeiten damit wird natürlich schwerer.
Transportieren wird schwerer.
Transportieren, zumindest wenn man es dann noch weiter vorschleppen muss, das Halten im, das Arbeiten mit wird einfach wirklich schwerer, handwerklich schwerer. Einfach ein größerer Aufwand.
Hydraulikstempel.
Hydraulikstempel, Hydraulikschere, genau. Und das letzte ist dann Hydraulik oder hydraulischer Spreizer, ein sogenannter, einfach das Gegenstück zur Schere. Den kann ich dann in eine kleine Öffnung reindrücken und mir halt dann auch wieder direkt auseinander. Als hätte ich eine Schere in geschlossen, die ich dann aufmache, wo ich dann irgendwelche Teile auseinanderdrücken kann. Oder auch was damit anheben, natürlich. Oder im Umkehrschluss, wenn ich ihn offen hab und schließe, natürlich auch wieder was zusammenzudrücken. Zusammendrücken oder mit Ketten dran auch was auseinander dran ziehen.
Ahja, um was weiß ich, irgendwas anderes ran zu hängen und es fehlt noch 10 cm oder so.
Ja, das nicht, aber um wirklich irgendwas ein kurzes Stück hoch zu ziehen und ein Auto unten, dann kann ich das natürlich auch verwenden.
Einfach Erfahrungssache, was man nimmt.
Genau, das ist nachher wirklich Improvisation. Was muss ich jetzt hier machen? Welche Möglichkeiten habe ich? Wir haben halt die beschränkten Möglichkeiten, dahinten ist das Fahrzeug. Was machen wir jetzt damit? Oder wir haben ja Aufgabe, hier ist das Fahrzeug, bitte lösen.
Ist das nicht schon ein bisschen wieder auch Teil des Kicks, solche Situationen lösen zu müssen? Ich meine, man muss sehr schnell sein zum Einsatzverlauf, wenn wir sicherlich gleich nochmal kommen. Aber ist ja klar, man muss irgendwie schnell am Start sein, muss schnell seine Equipment beisammen haben, man muss schnell vor Ort sein. Und dann muss man aber auch immer einen klaren Blick dafür offen haben und dann die richtige Entscheidung durchführen, um dann einfach im jeweiligen Moment einfach das Richtige zu tun.
Genau, das kommt einfach dann dazu. Am Anfang läuft es natürlich automatisch. Okay, ich muss ins Gerätehaus, ich muss aufs Fahrzeug drauf. Vielleicht hat man schon mitgekriegt, was es genau ist, kann sich schon Gedanken machen.
In welchem Zustand befindet man sich da, wenn man so im Einsatz ist?
Es ist schon natürlich ein gewisser Puls. Man hat geguckt, dass man einigermaßen sicher und verhältnismäßig schnell ans Gerätehaus kommt. Mit den heutigen Mitteln weiß man meistens schon, um was es grob geht, weil einem das bei der Alarmierung mitgeteilt wurde. Man zieht sich um, schaut, welche Fahrzeuge noch frei sind, welche jetzt überhaupt raus muss, welche überhaupt gebraucht wird. Man setzt sich dann darauf, irgendwann ist das Fahrzeug voll. Oder leider nicht voll, aber man sagt trotzdem, das muss reichen, wir fahren jetzt schon mal.
Lass uns das mit dem Einsatz gleich nochmal machen. Das interessiert mich noch mal separat. Aber wir waren ja eben noch bei der Technik. Vielleicht, dass wir das erstmal zusammen kriegen. Also wir hatten so die ganze Löschgeschichte, also Wassertank, die Schläuche, verschiedene Größen, Adapter, Climbim und vor allem dieser Aufsatz.
Also zum Löschen kommt noch mehr dazu.
Genau, dann hast du aber die ganze Hydraulikgeschichte zum Zusammenpressen, auseinanderschieben und wegdrücken usw. erwähnt. Was ist noch ein wichtiges Element auf diesem Löschfahrzeug, mit dem man so in den Einsatz fährt?
Also zu dem ganzen Hydraulikequipment kommt jetzt einfach noch das handwerkliche Zubehör dazu, ein Handwerkskasten, Unterbaumaterial, wenn ich wirklich was abstützen will, muss ich es auch nachher noch mal unterbauen, dass es mir nicht runterkommt. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt irgendwie schon 30 cm geschafft. Okay, schiebe ich ein paar Holzbalken drunter, dass es bei den 30 cm bleibt und setze dann vielleicht aber wieder auf denen auf, um von denen aus weiterzumachen. Ich habe Druckluftkissen dabei, sprich irgendwelche Gummikissen, denen ich Druckluft zugebe und dann kann ich mit denen was anheben, auch wieder ein Auto anheben, Auto abstützen, irgendwas anders anheben. Ich kann die aber auch nehmen, um zum Beispiel einen Kanal abzudichten, indem ich irgendwie ein kleines kugeliges Kissen in den Kanal reinstecke, entsprechend Druckluft draufgebe und dann ist der Kanal abgedichtet, dann können da keine Flüssigkeiten mehr reinlaufen. Kommt mit dazu. Was haben wir da noch drauf? Auf dem Fahrzeug zum Beispiel einen sogenannten Sprungretter. Du kennst vielleicht von früher noch diese Sprungtücher. Etwas bessere Bettlagen, sprich Sprungtücher. Kennt man vielleicht aus irgendeinem Film, dass dann 15 Feuerwehrleute da stehen müssen und sich alle zurücklehnen und an so einem Tuch reißen.
Der Klassiker.
Dass dann einer runterspringen darf oder der runterspringen möchte und der dann hoffentlich in dieses Tuch reinspringt. Was man gerade schon gemerkt hat, man braucht verhältnismäßig viel Personal dafür. 15 Leute hat man im Normalfall einfach nicht dabei. Das sind zwei Fahrzeuge und die sollten aber in der Zeit auch noch irgendwas anders tun. Eine Variante ist der sogenannte Sprungretter. Das heißt, wenn man sich das anguckt, es ist ein Gerät, ich sag jetzt mal, 3 auf 3 Meter, wenn es aufgeblasen ist, auch wieder mit Pressluft, mit Druckluft, in das man dann reinspringen kann.
Dreimal 3 Meter?
Dreimal 3 Meter breit in etwa, circa 2 Meter hoch. Das stellt man dann dorthin, wo die Person vermutlich runterspringen möchte, bläst es auf, bläst es am besten vorher auf, stellt es dann erst an die Stelle, fährt man aber, das ist eine psychologische Sache, da ist schon was, springt runter und ist noch gar nicht aufgeblasen. Ein bisschen fail dann. Ansonsten, man baut es vorher zusammen, lässt es aufblasen, trägt es an die passende Stelle. Das Schöne ist, das ist so leicht, das können zwei Personen locker tragen, auch wenn es unhandlich ist. Und es muss keiner mehr sichern, im Zeitpunkt des Runterspringens. Das hält man da dahin kurz. Das ist auch wirklich dasselbe Prinzip, denn es wird außen an Streben aufgeblasen, senkrechte und querstreben, und das hält das Ganze auf Spannung.
Das heißt, man muss nicht den kompletten Körper voll machen, sondern das ist einfach nur von Luft getragen, das Sprungtuch sozusagen. Ah ja, damit es schnell geht.
Das geht feldesmäßig schnell, das ist in einer Minute am Start.
Piffig.
Und braucht keine, diese 15 Leute, die es früher haben halten müssen. Und selbst das war noch sehr gefährlich. Braucht es einfach nicht mehr. Ist also für alle sicherer geworden. Und einfacher, leichter, schneller. So, was haben wir noch dabei?
Und die Puppe, die die Pneumatik pumpen, sind dann auch an Bord, natürlich?
Braucht man nicht. Da reicht im Normalfall so eine Pressluftflasche, wie man sie für Atemschutz auf dem Rücken trägt. Da braucht also kein Equipment. Direkt anschließen, aufdrehen, abwarten, voll.
Verstehe.
Ist also soweit wartungsfreundlich. Genau, ganz einfach. So, was haben wir sonst noch dabei? Zusatz-Equipment, wie zum Beispiel eine Motorsäge, Trennschleifer oder langläufig als Flex bekannt. Für die Motorsäge, für das ganze Zeug natürlich noch mal entsprechendes Schutzmaterial für uns. Schutzkleidung, dass man sich mit der Motorsäge auch nicht irgendwie ins Bein sägt. Man kann es zwar dennoch, aber da ist dann noch mal irgendwie eine spezielle Hose dazwischen, die sich dann in der Kette verfängt. Und dann noch mal ein Feuerlöscher, ein kleiner, ist natürlich auch dabei. Manchmal reicht es ja. Und dann noch zusätzliches Lösch-Equipment, wie zum Beispiel jetzt ein paar Kanister Schaummittel, die dann über einen speziellen Zumischer mit Wasser vermischt werden und auch wieder in einem speziellen Strahlrohr dann zu Schaum gemacht werden. Wenn man also mal irgendwo einen Fahrzeugbrand sieht, wird der im Normalfall mit Schaum gelöscht, weil Wasser und dort allein nicht weiter reicht. Warum? Weil das Wasser, diese Brände mit Plastik drin, mit Benzin drin und so weiter, mit Wasser kriegt man Flüssigkeitsbrand nicht gelöscht, weil das dann die Flüssigkeit nur verteilt oder verdünnt. Das muss man dann einfach abdecken, und dann ist eher die Funktion des Luftabhaltens durch Schaum. Das heißt, der Schaum erstickt das Feuerwehr, während Wasser ist eher abkühlt und dadurch einfach löscht.
Ist das so umweltverträglich, dieser Schaum?
Mittlerweile denke ich ja. Da hat sich natürlich auch viel getan. Ich übe nicht so viel damit, aber das ist eher eine Preisfrage. Es gab früher mal speziellen, sehr umweltfreundlichen Schaum, also es ist immer noch einfach wie ein Spülmittel. Es muss natürlich einen gewissen Effekt haben, der es auf Schaum gibt. Es gab früher mal Schaum auf Eiweißbasis, zumindest für Übungszwecke, der aber den ekligen Effekt hatte, dass das irgendwann einfach angefangen hat zu stinken. Dass man gesagt hat, bitte mit dem, aber von dem hat man gar nichts. Genau. Klar, der Schaum ist natürlich, ich kann auch keine 5000 Liter Spülmittel mal irgendwo ins Wasser kippen. Da haben sie dann auch ein Problem damit. Aber das ist einfach auch wieder das Abwägen von Übeln. Entweder lasse ich es jetzt einfach fertig brennen und der Qualm, der dabei entsteht, ist natürlich auch nicht wirklich gesundheitsfördernd. Oder ich erstick das Ganze einfach mit Löschschaum und damit ist die Sache dann erledigt. Den Dreck haben wir eh schon durch den Brand.
Da da so viel Dreck und gesundheits- nicht gerade förderliches Zeug ist, ist ja dann wahrscheinlich auch das ganze Team auch noch amtlich Atemschutz am Start.
Das kommt dann mit dazu. Also zumindest die zwei bis vier Kameraden, die dann vorne sind, auch wirklich am Feuer, werden dann natürlich auch Atemschutz tragen. Sprich die Flasche auf dem Brücken, eine Maske im Gesicht, um sich da von der Umluft unabhängig zu machen.
Was hat man so an?
Was hat man zu Anfang unten an? Man hat Sicherheitsschuhwerk an, also sprich Stiefel, die irgendwie ölsicher, ölfest sein müssen. Die müssen eine durchtrittssichere Sohle haben, dass es sich dort kein Nagel eintritt.
Stahleinlage oder sowas?
Stahleinlage drin. Vorne natürlich einen Zehenschutz, also sprich eine Stahlkappe vorne drauf. Mittlerweile die etwas besseren Stiefel haben dann auch schon Umknickschutz drin, also wie man es jetzt von Wanderschuhen alles kennt. Dort Unterstützung und dann bis hoch. Meistens die neueren mittlerweile alle geschnürt und einen Reißverschluss, also einmal verschnürt und dann einen Reißverschluss zum schnellen Öffnen. So, Stiefel. Dann geht es weiter mit einer passenden Feuer-Einsatzhose. Bleiben wir einfach mal beim Extremfall-Atemschutz. Das heißt, man hat eine Hose, die auch mal ein Feuer abkann, die mit viel Glück etwas verstärktes, einen verstärkten Schutz auf dem Knie hat, dass ich mich auch irgendwo hinknien kann und dort ein bisschen geschützt bin und ich immer gleich den Boden bei mir spüre. Und im Normalfall geht die Hose mittlerweile, also es ist keine Bundhose, die nur irgendwie bis zu deinem Gürtel geht, sondern auch eine Latzhose. Das heißt, die Hose an sich schützt dich schon mal also sozusagen bis zur Brust hoch.
Und ist da auch so ein Temperaturabweiser drin? Ist da noch mal so Folie drin, die einfach noch die Hitze fernhält?
Da sind mittlerweile diverse Stoffe drin. Einer der bekanntesten ist jetzt zum Beispiel Nomex, was also gewisse Hitze abkann und dafür sorgt, dass du einfach diese Hitze erst nach einer gewissen Zeit auch mitkriegst. Also die Oberfläche fängt natürlich nicht gleich Feuer. Klar, man wird zwar sehen, wenn so eine Hose mal direkt Feuer abgekriegt hat, aber im Normalfall steht man ja auch nicht direkt am Feuer drin. Man wird das sehen, aber sie schützt dich zumindest vor direkter Feuerbeaufschlagung auch eine gewisse Zeit. So, das haben wir. Die Hose, bei den heutigen Hosen ist mittlerweile so, dass man nichts mehr drunter ziehen muss. Früher, bei den etwas älteren Hosen hieß es okay zum Schutz, hast du bitte deine Jeans aber auch noch unter. Deine eigene, mittlerweile brauchst du die nicht mehr. Brauchst sie nicht mehr anziehen. Das heißt, du kannst also sozusagen in der Unterhose, in die Hose rein, bist soweit geschützt. Im Sommer natürlich ist die Hose warm genug. Im Winter ist man froh drum. Obenrum geht es dann weiter, eine Feuerwehr-Einsatzjacke, kommen dann wieder dieselben Materialien an den Start, weil man dann dasselbe natürlich auch obenrum hätte. Klar. Man hat einfach Bündchen dann natürlich auch, dass es möglichst dicht ist, ein Kragen, der möglichst weit hoch geht, den ich zumachen kann. Die hält die Hitze ab, hat mittlerweile auch wieder ein paar Taschen drin, dass ich vielleicht doch noch irgendwie ein Funkgerät noch mitnehmen kann, was dann aus noch irgendwie in einer Tasche hängt. Dass ich mich da möglichst dick einpacken kann. Das Wasserdampf, der eigentlich bei einem Brand, bei dem Inneneinsatz das Kritischste ist. Feuer, in Feuer geht man im Normalfall gar nicht erst rein. Man steht nicht im Feuer, das macht man einfach nicht. Wasserdampf ist eigentlich das größte Problem, dass dort, wenn jetzt irgendwo an der Jacke wirklich was offen ist, das Wasserdampf vom Löschen dann irgendwie auf mich kommt und ich mich dann irgendwo verbrüh. Man holt sich im Normalfall keine Verbrennung, man holt sich irgendwo eine Verbrühung durch den Wasserdampf und das ist extrem eklig.
Ja, wer das schon mal in der Küche gehabt hat, wünscht sich das nicht mehr.
Ja, kann jeder gerne mal üben.
Aber nur in Schutzkleidung.
Genau. Wo geht's dann weiter? Handschuhe, natürlich auch noch mal dasselbe Spielchen. Man sollte immer noch mit greifen gehen, also sind immer noch Fingerhandschuhe, keine Fäustlinge. Die aber dann auch Hitze abkönnen, die auch Wasser abkönnen, auch Wasserdampf in gewissen Rahmen schützen. Aber im Normalfall ist auch der Handschuh, zumindest jetzt bei uns, würde ich jetzt sagen, ist der Handschuh das erste Teil der Bekleidung, wo du möglichst merkst, okay, jetzt ist langsam mal Schluss.
Womit man natürlich auch überhaupt erst die Gefährlichkeit einer Situation unter Umständen auch erahnt.
Genau, also kommt dann, früher hat man gesagt, okay, man will eigentlich an der Kleidung irgendwo ein sogenanntes Brand, ein Hitzefenster, ein Brandfenster, dem du dann merkst, okay, es ist jetzt wirklich heiß da draußen. Was machen wir hier drin eigentlich? Das ist heutzutage bei der ganzen Bekleidung natürlich nicht mehr so wirklich da. Du stehst in irgendwie einer Hitze drin, du hast irgendwie so ein 400 Grad um dich und merkst erst mal verhältnismäßig wenig davon.
Aber so auf der Haut irgendwie? Ich meine jetzt im Gesicht?
Nein, im Gesicht gemacht kurz weiter. Okay, du hast die Jacke, der Kragen ist hoch, der schließt im Normalfall, sag ich mal, bis zum Mund ab. Geht ungefähr auf die Höhe, also wie jetzt eine Winterjacke. Dann hast du dort drüber deine Atemschutzmaske drauf, die auch das ganze Gesichtsfeld einmal abdeckt. Nichts für Vollbartträger, natürlich. Und über der Maske hast du dann meistens auch wieder aus einem Nomex wie eine Sturmhaube, wie vom Moped fahren Sturmhaube auf, die einfach den Kopf in dem Teil, wo nicht die Maske ist, noch mal schützt. Auch noch mal einfach einen Hitzeschutz drauf. Einerseits natürlich ein direkter Flammenschutz, aber auch noch mal Hitzeschutz. Und dort drüber dann noch mal oben ein Feuerwehrhelm drauf, in verschiedenen Ausführungen. Bei dem hast du dann je nachdem auch noch mal mindestens einen kleinen Lederlatz hinten dran im Nacken, der dort noch mal schützt bzw. auch noch mal zusätzlich dran montiert, ein sogenanntes Holland-Tuch, was du auch noch mal um den Hals vorn noch mal zusätzlich schließen kannst.
Falls es richtig scheiße wird sozusagen.
Genau, d.h. du kriegst also dort vorne in dem Bereich, wo dann der Kragen eher vielleicht noch mal kurz offen ist, hast du einfach noch mal einen zusätzlichen Schutz drauf, dass dort einfach nichts schiefgeht. Und dann ist dann wirklich die Frage, wo merkst du jetzt denn überhaupt noch, dass da draußen Hitze herrscht? Klar.
Andererseits muss man halt auch schon irgendwie ran an den ganzen...
Genau, du solltest natürlich die Erfahrung haben, aber das abschätzen zu können, was machst du denn jetzt da überhaupt? Aber du bist bestmöglich dafür geschützt.
Ja, so, jetzt haben wir, also wir haben jetzt sicherlich noch die eine oder andere Technologie unerwähnt gelassen, aber ich denke, da kommen wir noch mal drauf. Was mich interessieren würde, ist, wie läuft das jetzt eigentlich so ab? Du sitzt jetzt hier, du hast ja irgendwie auch einen Pager, der dich im Prinzip, der jetzt jederzeit losgehen kann. Ist das ein Pager oder?
Das ist das, was man eigentlich früher irgendwie in dem, früher als, wie hießen die Geräte damals eben? Euromessage, oder die etwas billigeren waren als Quicks und Konsorten.
Aber sind die jetzt nicht, werden die nicht gerade alle abgeschaltet?
Ich nicht richtig weiß, die einzigen, die noch so wirklich existieren, sind Euromessage. Alles andere hat mit dem Siegeszug dieses komischen GSM-Entriere jetzt hier irgendwann mal aufgegeben, weil die Preise doch viel zu hoch waren und man dann halt jetzt überteuerte SMS schickt.
Aber im Feuerwehrbereich sind Pager auf jeden Fall noch verbreitet.
Genau. Das ist ein Pager. Das ist auch wirklich das Mittel, dass man dann also wirklich genau das, was damals so ein Pager war, selbe Betriebsarten, selbe Techniken, wie jetzt die Daten hier übertragen werden, das ist genau das. An meinem Beispiel ist jetzt ein sogenannter digitaler Meldeempfänger, der deswegen digital ist, weil er auch Daten direkt übertragen kriegt. Also auch genau wirklich wie früher Quicks und Euromessage. Da kommt ein Signal, was man irgendwie, wenn man es am Funk anhört, kurz rauscht oder brummt. Rauschen, AFSK, wenn es denn wirklich technisch interessiert ist, die Modulationsart, den das übertragen wird. Und dann landet dann ein Text drauf, auf dem dann steht, okay, Einsatz dort und dort.
Bist du immer im Einsatz? Also ich meine, bist du immer für einen Einsatz abrufbar?
Technisch gesehen ja. Allerdings bin ich jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn ich hier im Büro sitze, einfach nicht erreichbar. Liegt unter anderem auch daran, dass es auch jetzt, dass ich 35 Minuten bräuchte, bis ich irgendwie zur Verfügung stünde, wenn denn was wäre.
Weil du nicht in deinem eigentlichen Heimatort bist.
Genau, und weil ich hier einfach auch keinen Empfang habe. Das ist ein Nachbarlandkreis und dann schlägt das hier drüben nicht so gut ein.
Okay, aber wenn du jetzt nach Hause fährst, im Prinzip...
Dann stehe ich zur Verfügung....
einen schönen Kinoabend geplant.
Genau, und dann pfeift's und dann hat sich das mit dem Kino erledigt.
Und das machst du dann auch immer? Oder bist du dann verpflichtet zu kommen?
Ja, also mal ganz grob gesagt, das einzige Freiwillige an der Feuerwehr ist der Eintritt. Letztendlich gibt es dann, wie in jedem Büro oder Job, die Pflichten und Rechte des Feuerwehrmanns. Und mit Pflichten steht halt, hat den Einsatzdienst irgendwie pflichtgemäß.
Also es ist eine freiwillige Verpflichtung?
Du gehst freiwillig rein und dann wird es halt ein wenig schwierig.
Um dich dann verpflichten zu lassen?
Nein, verpflichtet sind wir alle nicht in dem Sinn.
Ja, okay, aber wenn du sagst, du kannst, also was heißt das?
Ich könnte jederzeit sagen, okay, ich hör jetzt auf damit.
Ja, aber du kannst jetzt nicht einen Einsatz ablehnen.
Aber im Normalfall kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, zu diesem komischen Einsatz, weil ich vielleicht schon sehe, was es ist, da will ich jetzt nicht hingehen. Wenn man nachher natürlich irgendjemand rauskriegt, der ist doch gerade durchs Dorf gefahren, wieso hast du das nicht gekriegt? Kann ich mich natürlich noch rausreden mit, der Pager hat gerade keinen Empfang gehabt. Aber bei dem Enden mal wird dann schon nachgefragt, willst du nicht mal einen neuen Pager haben?
Ja, naja gut, es kann ja auch sein, dass du selber krank bist oder dich aus anderen Gründen nicht einsatzfähig hältst.
Wenn ich wirklich krank bin und sage, okay Jungs, ich liege im Bett und dafür dann kann ich es gerade gar nicht.
Meldest du dich dann aber auch zurück und explizit nicht zum Einsatz?
Nein, das gibt es in dem Sinn nicht vorgesehen.
Okay, also das heißt, wenn so ein Einsatzhof rausgeht, dann tauchen...
Geht das mal Bankspiel los, wie viel kommen denn da jetzt? Genau, wir drücken auf den Knopf, wir wissen, okay, maximal können jetzt irgendwie 27 Leute kommen oder irgendwas.
Was wäre denn jetzt mal wirklich ein guter Fall? Also was für ein Einsatz könnten wir uns jetzt mal... Was ist denn passiert?
Also wir sagen jetzt irgendwie mal...
Was typisch ausreichend spannend ist.
Typisch ausreichend spannend.
Muss ja jetzt nicht immer das brennende Haus sein.
Ich schau jetzt mal kurz, was hat man jetzt hier irgendwie Schönes drauf? Was typisch und interessant wäre... Ja, sag mal, mit diesem Fahrzeug brandt da. Okay.
Das heißt, Autounfall oder?
Nö, das hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen, wir wissen auch nicht weswegen, das hat einfach angefangen zu brennen. Das machen Autos.
Ja, ich weiß, ich komm ja aus Berlin.
Da ist das mit den Kfz-Brennen, glaub ich, ein bisschen anders. Da gibt es ein paar regionale Häufungen.
Das heißt, irgendjemand meldet das, hier 112 an der Ecke, sowieso Straße, ein Auto brennt.
Ja, damals war das sogar mein Auto brennt. Aber nicht dein Auto? Nein, also die haben angerufen, wir sind hier gerade gefahren und auf einmal hat unser Auto angefangen brennen.
Dann standen sie mitten auf der Autobahn. Verstehe, mitten auf der Autobahn. Und was geht dann ab? Also geht der Rettungsruf rein?
Genau, dann ist irgendwo auf der Leitstelle, also bei uns in Walzow zum Beispiel, auf der Leitstelle hat einer angerufen, ja, hören Sie mal zu, wir stehen hier und hier, mein Auto brennt.
Dann ist eigentlich schon relativ klar, was der Bedarf ist.
Dann ist eigentlich schon verhältnismäßig auch alles gesagt, ja, keiner mehr im Auto, nee, sitzt keiner mehr drin, wichtigste schon mal erledigt, irgendjemand verletzt, ja, nee, eigentlich nicht, wunderbar. Viel schöner kann für die Feuerwehr nachher so ein Fahrzeugbrand dann eigentlich gar nicht laufen, weil eklig wird es halt immer dann, wenn es heißt, okay, sind noch Personen eingeklemmt, das wird dann natürlich dann gleich auch ein bisschen, man ist aufgeregter, wenn man das natürlich mitkriegt. So, dann heißt es irgendwie, dort draußen brennt ein Auto, man sieht es dann irgendwie auf dem Pager, der piepst, man...
Das heißt, auf dem Pager wird schon vermittelt, worum es geht?
Genau, also ich habe jetzt hier so genannten Text-Pager. Das ist jetzt der Vorteil, seit wir diese digitalen Meldeempfänger haben, der zeigt mir jetzt im Text wirklich einen Text an, okay, Einsatzecke dort und dort, das und das ist los.
Okay, und wo gehst du dann hin? Gehst du dann direkt zu diesem Einsatzort? Oder musst du eigentlich erstmal zur Feuerwehr, du musst ja deine Ausrüstung nehmen?
Genau, also wir haben unsere Ausrüstung im Geräthaus, im Feuerwehrhaus. Das heißt, ich muss erst dorthin, muss mich umziehen. Falls ich jetzt auch noch der Erste bin, müsste ich auch erst bei der Leitstelle Bescheid geben. Hurra, wir sind jetzt da.
Und wie kommst du dann dahin? Ich meine, wenn du jetzt irgendwo in der Pampa stehst, nimmst du dir ein Taxi oder bist du jetzt kein Auto am Start?
Wenn ich in der Pampa stehe, wird es verhältnismäßig schwierig, dann dort noch hinzukommen. Dann kann man natürlich sagen, okay, ich nehme ein Taxi. Oder man sagt sich, hey, bis ich jetzt daheim bin, entweder ich renne irgendwie ins Geräthaus oder ich renne schnell heim oder ich mache ein dummes Gesicht. Das kann einfach nicht kommen.
Das ist schon mal Teil der Abwägung, ob man überhaupt zum Einsatz fährt oder nicht.
Genau, das kommt einfach dazu. Wenn es einfach nicht machbar ist, oder ich bin jetzt wirklich in Orten und Weiß halbe Stunde fahren, wenn ein Fahrzeug brandt, okay, lohnt nicht.
Was war das für eine Tageszeit?
Das war, jetzt muss ich gerade mal nachgucken. Mitten in der Nacht, 0.07 Uhr, besser kann es nicht sein.
Besser kann es nicht sein?
In der Nacht, weil nachts die Leute für gewöhnlich zu Hause sind. Und nicht in der Arbeit. Da die Leute mittlerweile nicht mehr zu Hause, also in dem Ort, in dem sie wohnen, arbeiten, sondern meistens ein paar Kilometer weiter, ist einfach tagsüber irgendwie die schlechteste Uhrzeit für jeglichen Feuerwehrensatz.
Also wenn man mal sein Auto brennen lassen möchte, dann besser nachts.
Wenn man es gelöscht haben möchte.
Wenn man es gelöscht haben möchte, okay. Und wacht man denn immer auf von diesem Pager?
Ja, ich habe jetzt persönlich überhaupt kein Problem wegen irgendeinem komischen digitalen Piepsen irgendwo, was auch nur ein einziges sein müsste, kurz aufzurachen.
Okay, da bist du wahrscheinlich auch voll drauf puriert.
Man ist halt auch irgendwie als, ich denke als Nerd, einfach mal grundsätzlich dafür, irgendwelches Piepsen antrainiert. Handy leer? Was war es denn?
Ach, Autobrand.
Ja, das piepst schon ein bisschen anders. Also piepst du auch natürlich ein bisschen lauter als sonst was. Ich hab's im Normalfall auch einfach auf dem Nachttisch liegen, das Gerätchen.
Okay, dann musst du halt schnell los. Du musst ja auch noch nicht mal die Hose anziehen, weil du hast ja ja schon in deinem Feuerwehr...
Sollte mir doch mal ein bisschen was anziehen, genau. Runter ans Auto, ab ins Gerätehaus.
Darf er gehen?
Nein. Also im Normalfall, bis ich im Gerätehaus bin, vergehen, ich sag jetzt mal, schlechtestens mit irgendwelcher komischen Verpeilungen, weil es halt...
Mit Aufwachen und so?
Mit Verpeilung und nachts, weil es Tiefschlafphase war, sag ich jetzt mal drei Minuten.
Drei Minuten?
Ich war noch verhältnismäßig nah.
Und wie viele Leute schlagen da auf?
Da würde ich mal sagen, da sind jetzt in etwa bei diesem Brand sind jetzt, sag ich jetzt mal, 20 Leute aufgeschlagen. Ich würde es so angucken.
20.
6, 9...
Das ist ja mehr als man braucht, oder?
Also die Alarmierung... Wir gehen noch kurz vor. Jetzt hat jemand auf der Leitstelle angerufen, okay, Fahrzeugbrand. Es handelt sich um normalen PKW. Okay, also wird irgendwie... Weißt du, dieser Leitstellendisponent, der also die Einstellungen disponiert, der dann entscheidet, bei einem Brand dieser Größe von dies und das, also ein Auto oder ein Haus, muss ich das und das alarmieren. Das ist in dem Einsatzleitrechner, den er dort hat, bereits hinterlegt, weil das mal jemand festgelegt hat. Und er weiß dann auch, okay, es ist ein Laufenburg, also muss ich die und diese schleifen, oder heutzutage heißen die RICs, alarmieren, dass von so und so vielen Leuten der Pager einfach piepst und die dann auch alle kommen.
Also RICs sind jetzt sozusagen Alarmierungsgruppen?
Alarmierungsgruppen, genau.
Das heißt, wie viele Leute werden so alarmiert, wenn 20 bei rauskommen? 100?
Alle? Nein, das sind jetzt...
Schon alle?
Das ist, wenn ich das jetzt so sehe, ist die komplette Abteilung Laufenburg alarmiert worden. Das heißt, er hat in etwa... Was wird alarmiert? Haben 50, 60 Leute?
Davon kommt jeder Dritte?
Nein, wir hätten... Da sind sicher mehr gekommen, als jetzt hier ausgerückt sind. Wir hätten auch noch ein zusätzliches Fahrzeug, die unsere Drehleiter zum Beispiel, ist jetzt nicht rausgefahren, die hätte man jetzt auch noch ausstatten können. Und es sind sicher auch noch ein paar Leute übrig geblieben.
Das heißt, es kann auch gut sein, dass man da aufläuft und dann gar nichts zu tun hat?
Genau. Ist natürlich immer schade. Für den, der irgendwie alarmiert wurde und sagt, jetzt war endlich mal wieder was, jetzt bin ich gekommen, durfte aber gar nichts machen. Also es kommt auf die Person natürlich an. Und wenn jemand schon irgendwie dauernd am Nörgeln ist, dann würde ihm sowas natürlich auch nicht gefallen.
Also es ist eher die Enttäuschung, dass man nicht mitfahren darf, als dass man jetzt geweckt wurde?
Das ist vielleicht schon eher auch zum Teil das, jetzt bin ich geweckt worden. Also es kommt auf die Person ziemlich an. Ein Jungtlicher, ein etwas Jüngerer, der sagt, ha ha Einsatz und, na Mist, war ich wieder irgendwie an zwei Dörfern weiter und hab zu lange gebraucht, kein Platz mehr auf dem Fahrzeug gewesen, durfte nicht mit. Der sagt sich natürlich schade und, nächstes Mal vielleicht mehr Glück.
Okay, und dann rückt man irgendwie aber an, ins Gerätehaus und dann muss man erstmal in den ersten Stock, damit man dann auch schön theatralisch wieder die Stange runterrutschen kann.
Stange runterrutschen haben wir jetzt bei uns zum Beispiel nicht.
Was?
Weil alles ebenerdig ist. Stange runterrutschen ist jetzt vielleicht eher eine Erfindung der wirklich Berufsfeuerwehren mit, also Feuerwehren, wo Leute die ganze Zeit sind, zum Beispiel ihre Offenheitsräume im ersten Stock haben und dann runter in die Fahrzeughalle rutschen.
Die sind halt sozusagen immer auf Abruf vor Ort.
Genau.
Die sitzen da einfach rum, weil sie sind halt Berufsfeuerwehrleute.
Die machen tagsüber irgendwie Fahrzeugpflege oder machen Sport oder kochen auch oder machen was auch immer und sind dann auf Abruf und nachts schlafen sie auch. Und die sind dann meistens, weil man heutzutage nicht mehr nur baut, irgendwo in einem anderen Stock und können dann auch mal ein paar Stockwerke runterrutschen. Einzelne natürlich.
Okay, aber bei euch wird nicht gerutscht.
Bei uns wird nicht gerutscht. Das heißt, wir kommen dann an, ziehen uns um. Vielleicht weiß man dann schon, um was es geht. Das macht es dann verhältnismäßig einfach. Oder man kann sich einfach im Kopf auch schon mal auf die Situation einstellen. Was hätte ich denn zu machen, je nachdem, wo ich jetzt auf welches Fahrzeug ich komme?
Wer übernimmt denn dann die Leitung des Einsatzes?
Die Einsatzleitung übernimmt im Normalfall jetzt der Kommandant der Feuerwehr, der Stadtkommandant.
Der ist dann wahrscheinlich eh schon vor Ort, oder was?
Der ist vor Ort, weil der fährt meistens einfach mit seinem Privat-Pkw direkt hin.
Ach so, der ist am Einsatzort? Ach so, verstehe.
Der fährt meistens direkt an den Einsatzort. Ist dann da schon mal, und meistens ist er natürlich die drei Minuten, die ich bis ins Gerätehaus brauche, ist er vielleicht schon am Einsatzort. Kann dann den, die dort sind und losfahren, würden aber schon mal sagen, braucht nicht so viel, oder bringt man auch das zusätzlich?
Okay, aber der ist jetzt nicht in dieser ganzen Einsatzklamotte am Start, sondern der...
Doch, der hat das Zeug im Koffer auf.
Ach so, okay, verstehe.
Und zieht sich dann einfach auf dem Weg dorthin schnell um. Also vorher. Ist dann schon vor Ort, so der Rest. Weist dann nach einer sogenannten Einsatz- und Alarmordnung, oder Einsatz- und Ausrückerordnung, weist dann bei diesem... Bei diesem Einsatz-Stichwort müssen wir die und die Fahrzeuge mitnehmen. Das rückt als erstes raus, das als zweites. Dann wird dann aufgefüllt, wenn voll, dann abhauen.
Einsatz-Stichworte, was heißt das?
Das Einsatz-Stichwort ist dann eben Brand. Da schaltet man dann einfach wieder drei Kategorien, Klein, Mittel, Groß, Verkehrsunfall, oder Verkehrsunfall mit eingeklemmter Person, Person im Wasser, Schiffsunfall. Das sind einfach die verschiedenen Einsatz-Stichworte, für die schon mal jemand im Vorhinein festgelegt wird, was dort alarmiert wird, um sich das einfach einfacher zu machen. Wenn das, dann okay, die, dann abhauen. Um einfach schon mal die Abläufe vorher einfach schon mal zu regeln. Man hat die Möglichkeit, also kann man es auch machen.
Ja, Zeit ist Erfolg, nicht wahr? Es muss halt immer alles schnell gehen und reibungslos gehen.
Man hat halt die Auflagen, in so und so vielen Minuten mit dem ersten Fahrzeug vor Ort zu sein. Und wenn es nicht immer nur gleich direkt ums Gerätehaus ist, man sofort wieder da ist, oder vielleicht auch mal irgendwann berghoch fahren muss, dann ist man froh um jede Minute, die man wirklich auch alle Leute da und wegfahren kann.
Und in dem Fall ist jetzt ein Löschzug ausgerückt, wahrscheinlich, weil es gereicht hat?
Ja, in dem Fall sind fünf Fahrzeuge raus, wenn ich das so richtig sehe.
Fünf? Also, die dicken, fetten, großen Teile, oder was?
Also sozusagen, es ist ein Einsatzleitwagen raus. Dort sitzt dann meistens ein Funker drin, der dann den ganzen Verkehr, was es dann vom Einsatzleiter zu den anderen Fahrzeugen zu managen gibt, abarbeitet. Der einfach Protokoll führt in dem Einsatz, alles was war, was er am Funk mitgekriegt hat, oder was jemand gesagt hat.
Also das ist nur ein fahrbares Büro?
Genau, das Büro für den Einsatzleiter sozusagen. Dort kann aber auch jemand drin sein, der das Ganze auch vom Einsatz selber her auch mit zusätzlich managt, der auch noch Ideen hat. Also es gibt da auch eine Normbesatzung natürlich, aber im Normalfall das fahrbare Büro des Einsatzleiters, wo einfach alles notiert, dokumentiert wird. Und auch mal gesagt, okay, besorg mal noch das, der kümmert sich darum, telefoniert, schickt einen Fax, empfängt einen Fax. Alles dabei.
Passt jetzt für das brennende Auto wahrscheinlich noch nicht so, dass man jetzt so viele Faxe schicken muss, aber man weiß ja nie.
Was natürlich sein kann, klassischer Fall, man hat ein Fahrzeug, das ist ein LKW, und der hat halt, weil man mal wieder Pech gehabt hat, so ein orangenes Schild, Gefahrgut dran.
Ah, genau.
Und dann hat man vielleicht selber ein Buch dabei oder ein Notebook, in dem man kurz nachgucken kann, was heißen denn jetzt die Nummern. Oder man gibt der Leitstelle Bescheid, hört mal zu, wir haben hier irgendwie Nummer 3306, irgendwas, schickt uns nochmal bitte per Fax schnell die Gefahrgutunterlagen zu diesem Stoff. Und dann kommt es per Fax, weil man hätte es auch gerne auf Papier, das ist einfach irgendwie viel besser.
Okay, verstehe.
Als nur per Telefon oder per Funk kurz erzählen.
Aber solche Gefahrgutunterlagen, muss man die nicht sowieso griffbereit haben?
Naja, die sind auf dem Fahrzeug drauf, auf dem Gefahrgut-Transporter.
Ach so, von diesem konkreten Fahrzeug jetzt?
Genau.
Ach so, verstehe.
Der hat die dabei, nur ob ich dann in dem Fall noch dran komme. Früher waren die...
Ich dachte, du meinst jetzt diese Nummernennzeichnung, in so einem Lastwagen steht doch hinten im Prinzip kodiert drauf, was er transportiert, oder?
Genau, steht einmal irgendwie die UN-Nummer, ist das der Stoff und drunter ist die Gefahrenkennzeichnung, die mir sagt, grob schon mal sagt, welche Gefahr von dem ausgeht. Aber den genauen Umgang mit dem Stoff, darf ich mit Wasser dran oder welchen Abstand muss ich halten bei den Gefahren, das steht letztendlich in dem Gefahrgutmerkblatt, was irgendwo auf dem Fahrzeug ist, in den Unterlagen. Früher hat das einen definierten Ort gehabt, mittlerweile ist es irgendwo im Führerhaus. Das liegt da einfach irgendwo. Muss zwar in der Sprache des Landes sein, durch die es durchgefahren wird, aber wenn die Karre brennt, sucht da keiner mehr drin.
Okay, ich hab gerade so ein Foto geklickt hier. Das sind diese orangenen Schilder mit den zwei Zahlen.
Genau, oben diese UN-Nummer, die den Stoff einfach ausmacht und unten steht dann, was der Stoff grob schon mal für gefährliche Eigenschaften hat.
Okay.
Ob er brennbar ist, ob es eine brennbare Flüssigkeit, ob sie sehr brennbare Flüssigkeit ist, ob sie mit Wasser gefährlich reagiert.
Ja, ist ja nicht ganz unerheblich.
Aber Pika-Wies haben das im Normalfall nicht dran. Transporter können es wieder dran haben. Da kommen wir dann wieder an die Krux der kleinen, schnellen Transporte, die eine auf der Autobahn immer überholen wollen. Kommt leider immer mehr, dass auch die Gefahr gut transportieren dürfen. Ach echt?
Diese giftigen Sprinter.
Genau. Leider ist es dann auch so, dass die alle Mindermengen, sogenannte Mindermengen transportieren. Das heißt, die haben dann zwar vielleicht ein rotes Schild hinten dran.
Mit hier ist etwas gefährlich, aber müssen nicht auszeichnen, was.
Das heißt, da ist irgendwas Gefährliches drin und keiner weiß was.
Ach super.
Genau.
Was sind diese roten?
Orangentafeln.
Gut. Zurück zu unserem Autobrand.
Das nächste Fahrzeug, ich denke mal, dass die Reihenfolge stimmt, was raus ist, war unser Tanklatschfahrzeug. Da sind wir dann wieder bei 2500 Liter Wasser an Bord.
Das reicht dann für so ein PKW?
Kann reichen.
Kann reichen. 2500 Liter Wasser an Bord. Sechs Mann an Bord. Einer links vorne, der fährt, einer rechts vorne, der dieses Fahrzeug managt. Da heißt er Gruppenführer im Normalfall. Einfach für diese Löschgruppe. In dem Fall ist es sogar eine Staffel, weil es nur sechs Personen sind. Aber es gibt in den Staffelführer an sich als Begriff nicht. Einer, der für diese für sich selbst und die anderen fünf dort zuständig und auch verantwortlich ist. Und den dann aber auch sagt, was zu machen ist.
Muss das jemand sein, der jetzt eine Qualifikation hat? Oder ist das dann sozusagen nur die Rolle in dem Moment?
Der sollte auch diese Qualifikation haben.
Okay, also das ist schon auch nochmal so ein Ranking.
Das ist die nächste Ausbildungsstufe. Genau, da gehört dann auch zwei Wochen Lehrgang an einer Landesfeuerwehrschule dazu.
Das heißt, es ist auch sehr wichtig, dass solche Leute dann auch beim Einsatz kommen?
Genau, und dann fährt man sich dann schon. Wir brauchen natürlich einen, der irgendwie diesen Fahrzeug dann managt, den Gruppenführer. Wir brauchen aber auch einen, der es fahren kann. Und das ist ein Lkw. Das heißt, wir brauchen irgendjemand mit Lkw-Führerschein. Und da ist dann immer natürlich das nächste Problem.
Kann man denn aber Lkw-Führerschein, also kann man wahrscheinlich auch bei der Feuerwehr machen, oder?
Nein, kann man nicht bei der Feuerwehr machen. Also mittlerweile ist es bislang so, dass du einfach einen Lkw-Führerschein brauchst. Den hat ja vielleicht die Feuerwehr bezahlt, weil sie gesagt hat, okay, wir hätten gern, dass du uns unterstützt, wenn da was ist. Wir zahlen dir den. Dafür musst du dann aber zum Beispiel dich einfach noch mal für fünf Jahre verpflichten. Für jedes Jahr, was du früher aufhörst, müsstest du uns ein Fünftel der Kosten zurückzahlen. Das ist so feldesmäßig gebräuchlich.
Aber bei den Kosten ist ja nicht unerheblich für Lkw.
Für einen simplen Lkw-Führerschein, ohne Prüfung für einen Anhänger, weil das auch dort mittlerweile wieder aufgetrennt wurde, sind wir bei 1.700 Euro. Oder du hast natürlich früher, kam das öfter vor, den Lkw-Führerschein per Bund gemacht. Die Leute nimmt man natürlich gerne, der kann den schon. Oder halt aus dem Job natürlich, kann natürlich auch sein. Lkw-Fahrer ist irgendwo und dann hat er dort den Führerschein gemacht.
Okay, also das Team, das zusammenkommen muss, muss einfach ausreichende Anzahl Fahrer haben, ausreichende Anzahl an, aber ich denke mal Führerschein und Lkw-Führerschein-Quote ist nicht gerade gering, oder? Hast du einen?
Mir haben sie auch gezahlt. Ich habe Onkelzahlen gekriegt.
Und du darfst auch mit dem großen Onkel fahren?
Machst du Spaß? Gehört natürlich eine gewisse Fahrantwortung dazu.
Ich bin immer auf der Suche nach der Motivation, das gehört bestimmt auch dazu.
Es gehört auch eine Verantwortung dazu natürlich, die Kiste zu fahren, 14 Tonnen, 5 bis 8 Kameraden zusätzlich noch mit drauf, die auch dann sicher ankommen sollten, wenn es ein Einsatz ist.
Gört schon was dazu, vor allem, wenn es richtig mit Lalü-Lala durch die Straßen geht. So, was haben wir noch für Fahrzeuge am Start?
Das nächste ist dann zusätzlich noch, wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Was hatten wir bisher? Wir hatten das Einsatzfahrzeug, wir hatten das Tanklöschfahrzeug.
Genau, und das Tanklöschfahrzeug, was nochmal 2500 Liter Wasser dabei hat.
Okay, zwei, und da waren noch drei.
Genau, dann ist noch ausgerückt das nächste Löschfahrzeug. Zusätzlich noch, da ist auch nochmal Wasser mit drauf. Da sind dann aber auch die großen Rettungsgeräte wie hydraulische Geräte dabei, falls man es bräuchte.
Ja, ist aber beim Brand eher unwahrscheinlich, oder?
Bei einem Brand im Normalfall unwahrscheinlich, aber wir haben dort einfach nochmal Wasser dabei. Und zusätzlich könnten sich die dann auch darum kümmern, aus irgendeinem Hydrant aus einer Entfernung Wasser zu besorgen, eine Leitung zu legen.
Aber würde man das nicht mit einem auch?
Ja, aber da habe ich nur sechs Leute drauf. Und davon fällt es irgendwie der eine oder der Maschinist, der es gefahren hat und der auch die Pumpe bedient. Der Gruppenführer wird garantiert nicht über die Gegend rennen und Schläuche legen.
Sondern die Gruppe führen?
Zwei Mann schicke ich nach vorn, die das Fahrzeug löschen sollen, die dann auch Atemschutz anziehen. Und für die zwei sollte ich dann auch einen Rettungstrupp, falls denen was passiert haben, der auch schon sich mit Atemschutz ausrüstet.
Ja, dass die gegebenenfalls gerettet werden können.
Und dann sind die Jobs gleich mal schon mal verteilt.
Klar, man muss ja auch seine eigenen Leute noch sichern.
Genau, das heißt, nächste Fahrzeug ist gekommen und ich denke mal, dass die dann zumindest die Aufgabe hatten, für Wasser zu sorgen. Wobei, wenn ich mir jetzt genau an diesen Einsatz zurückerinnere, wäre es schwierig gewesen, Wasser zu kriegen. Wir haben einfach noch gekommen, wir haben nochmal Material dazugekriegt. Die haben dann vielleicht zusätzlich oder einfach nur ausgeläuchtet. Hingefahren, das Stromaggregat ausgeklagt, Mast aufs Dach, den Mast auf dem Dach einfach ausgefahren und für Licht gesorgt. Dann sind die vielleicht dann nur noch rumgestanden, aber nun gut.
Muss halt irgendwie, ja, das Zeug muss da hin. Oder waren da noch zwei Fahrzeuge?
Dann haben wir noch einen Gerätewagentransporter, also einen simplen Transporter mit Pritsche, der entweder nur Personen gebracht hat oder vielleicht irgendwelches Absperrmaterial nochmal zusätzlich für später. Drei Absperrschilder, große Feuerwehreinsatz, was auch immer. Und zusätzlich noch von einer anderen Abteilung ein Fahrzeug, kleineres, kein Wasser an Bord, aber auch ein Löschfahrzeug, auch nochmal mit neuen Leuten, mit einem großen Anhänger mit Schläuchen. Das heißt, da hätten wir dann auch nochmal eine Wasserförderung über eine gewisse Strecke mitmachen können.
Falls irgendwo ein Teich ist oder so?
Genau.
Wie genau weiß man denn, wo man eigentlich hinfährt?
Das ist die Sache. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie gucke, was haben wir dort gesagt gekriegt? Einsatzort hieß A 98 zwischen A und B. Okay, mit viel Glück hat man jetzt, das wäre jetzt eine Strecke gewesen, okay, eine Strecke von zwei Kilometern. Das geht. Das wird wirklich bei diesem Fall hieß A 98 zwischen hier und dort. Okay, zwei Kilometer, das kriegen wir hin. Hinfahren, suchen. Fahrzeugband nachts findet man ja.
Macht auf sich aufmerksam.
Außerdem kommt man dann auch schon direkt hin und kann dann gleich sagen, ah, es ist dort und dort.
Okay, und dann gibt es auch gleich GPS-Koordinaten oder wie? Nein.
GPS-Koordinaten braucht man, wenn man ja irgendwie eine Straße hat oder eine Hausnummer, braucht man noch kein GPS.
Okay, ich könnte mir ja nur vorstellen, dass es jetzt irgendwie so ein Gerät gibt, wo man dann einfach, wenn man vor Ort ist, auf eine Taste drückt und dann wird das automatisch übermittelt und dann poppen gleich überall die Google Maps Karten auf. Also gerade im Hinblick so, ich hab ja jetzt nur drüber nachgedacht, wo krieg ich Wasser her? Da muss man ja auch wissen, wo sind Hydranten? Was weiß ich, ist da ein Teich? Ist da ein Fluss? Irgendwie mit einer Nacht, man kennt die Gegend nicht?
Naja, man sollte sie kennen.
Die Gegend? Ja gut, ihr wohnt ja da auch, aber...
Genau, deswegen hat es ja Lokale und deswegen sollten sie die Gegend kennen. Ansonsten mit Hydranten, man hat im Normalfall, zumindest hätten wir jetzt auf dem Einsatzleitwagen, hätten wir Karten drauf. Kartenmaterial, wo genau drin steht, okay, wir sind jetzt in dem Ort, rausholen, Hydranten haben wir hier, dort, da, okay, der nächste ist da vorn.
Also man muss gar nicht mal nach irgendwelchen Schildern gucken, die darauf hinweisen, konkret?
Die Schilder helfen dir ja im Normalfall eh, nachts helfen sie dir sowieso nicht, weil du sie einfach nicht siehst. Im Normalfall weißt du, ist irgendjemand dabei, der weiß, okay, hier ist der nächste Hydrant da vorn, da können wir das Wasser holen. Die Schilder helfen dann nur noch zum wirklich genauen Finden. Wo war es jetzt da an der Ecke? Zwei Meter weg und drei Meter senkrecht. Das ist dann im Normalfall das. So, und dann sind dann die ganzen Fahrzeuge eigentlich vor Ort.
Also viel Löschkapazität für den Fall, dass man da jetzt, also, dass man einfach genug rumlöschen kann ohne jetzt.
Weil es einfach doch nicht nur das Ablöschen ist. Meistens muss man dann warten, bis die Polizei da war, als man mal reingeguckt hat, muss vielleicht selber dafür sorgen, dass das anständig abgesperrt wird, weil die Polizei grad überlastet ist und einfach nicht die Möglichkeit hat, dort abzusperren. Dann kann man entweder selber irgendwie absperren oder man stellt einfach ein Fahrzeug quer und dann ist die Sache einfach erstmal zu.
Da wird auch die Straße einfach mal gesperrt. Weil wichtiger ist das.
Weil es erstmal nicht unsere Aufgabe ist, Verkehr zu regeln, wir können nur Verkehr absperren. Das machen wir dann einfach auch. Verkehr regeln darf nur die Polizei.
Und die Fahrt zum Einsatz, die findet dann eigentlich schon irgendwie unter Einsatz von Höchstgeschwindigkeit statt, oder?
Nein, Höchstgeschwindigkeit nicht. Aber das ist dann das von dir beschriebene Lally. Sprich, dann kommen dann so Begriffe wie Sonderrechte und Wegerechte an Start. Das ist also natürlich ein sehr, ein Jura-Problem. Das Ganze, ein rechtliches Problem. Also das Fahrzeug wird ausrücken. Es wird dann vorne auf zwei Knöpfe gedrückt. Einmal das Blu-Licht auf dem Dach leuchtet. Einmal das dazu auch Lalü macht, dass so ein Martinshorn mit dazu am Start kommt. Und dann ist erstmal natürlich die Nachbarschaft geweckt. Das hat's dann nachts einfach. Zusätzlich holt man sich dort damit dann auch die Sonder- bzw. auch das Wegerecht, dass man auch mal etwas schneller an den Einsatzort fahren darf oder auch Vorfahrt sozusagen hat, wenn man es mal nicht hätte.
Aber bei jetzt so brennenden Autos macht man es nicht unbedingt, wo jetzt keine Leute in Gefahr sind, übertreibt man es nicht oder schon so schnell wie möglich?
So schnell wie möglich, so zügig wie möglich, genau. Und so sicher wie möglich. Also es ist nicht allein die Höchstgeschwindigkeit, die zählt.
Na ist klar, man muss natürlich das richtige Mittel finden. So ein großer Löschzug mit einer dicken Leiter, das ist ja ein fettes Teil.
Genau, das ist immer noch ein LKW. Das heißt, der hat im Normalfall im Ordner Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 50 oder Außerort 60, Autobahn 80. Das ist das, was sich rechtlich hindert. Und du guckst an, dass du denen möglichst sicher, wenn du dann halt mal irgendwo um die Kurve musst, auch nicht so schnell wie im Pkw, dort ankommst.
Sollte das schon mal geblitzt worden?
Ich wüsste nicht.
Ich meine, du weißt ja nicht, wie viele Blitzer bei euch rumstehen.
Also wir haben jetzt keine festen Blitzer.
Greta, wir waren keine Tickets zugeschickt.
Da könnte man es auch nicht einfach mal drauf anlegen, zehn schneller, damit es auch blitzt. Da kämen dann im Normalfall auch keine Blitzer an. Selbst wenn jetzt auch jemand von uns zum Gerätehaus fährt und geblitzt werden würde, ist es nach einer Abwägungssache.
Was ist eure Erfahrung, wie gut der Verkehr so mitspielt, wenn man mit La Lula unterwegs ist, gerade wenn es Schiefverkehr ist?
Also im Normalfall klappt es. Und wenn du dann halt jemanden hast, in seinem Thumb-Mobil vor dir, wo du halt schon im Fahrzeug merkst, da hinten waren die Boxen, bis der das mitkriegt, ist das ein bisschen schwierig. Die dürfen alles machen, die dürfen halt nicht vorschrägt dann einfach mal in die Klötze gehen. Dann hängst du den hinten drauf. Wenn der vor dir ist und auf einmal in seinem Rückspiegel nur noch irgendwie Rücklichter sieht, dann ist irgendwas schiefgelaufen bei dem. Im Normalfall klappt das. Wenn du dann wirklich Blaulicht und Horn anmachst, halten sie auch an, lassen dich auf die Straße an einer großen Kreuzung, einer vielbefahrenen. Im Normalfall klappt das. Du kommst einfach zügiger durch, als wenn du mit deinem Pkw ganz normal dort hinfahren würdest und einfach erst mal anstehen müsstest an allen anderen.
Martins wollen wir eigentlich alle haben, aber... Das ist ja auch schon sinnvoll, dass nicht jeder einen hat. So, der Rest ergibt sich ja nur so ein bisschen. Dann seid ihr irgendwie vor Ort und dann muss gelöscht werden. Genau. In dem Fall kommt der Schaum zum Einsatz.
In dem Fall sogar beides. Das heißt, wir haben erst mit Wasser gelöscht. Weil wir das schneller da haben, dann müssen wir in dem Fall für diesen Fall ein sogenannter Schnellangriff. Da ist ein druckfester Schlauch dran, wie ein Gummischlauch, wie du ihn jetzt sozusagen ein bisschen aus dem Garten kennst. Ein bisschen festerer Gummischlauch drauf, der auch fertig aufgerollt ist, den ich nur nehmen muss, die Sicherung lösen, rausziehen kann, vorlaufen kann. Der ist auch schon innen fest angeschlossen an die Pumpe. Das heißt, da müssen dann hinten die richtigen Regler bedient werden. Dann ist da Wasser drauf, dann kann ich da direkt loslöschen, ohne erst einen Schlauch ausrollen zu müssen, verkuppeln, Strahlrohr voran zu hängen.
Schnell sein.
Genau. Und in der Zeit haben dann ein paar andere Kameraden irgendwie noch das alles für den Schaum gerichtet, dass man dann den Rest des Feuers dann auch mit Schaumlöschen ablöschen konnte. Abdecken.
Und dann geht das wahrscheinlich auch relativ zügig.
Dann geht das verhältnismäßig zügig. Also wenn dann wirklich, wenn man dann mal Schaum hat, ist so ein Pkw-Brand, das war jetzt hier ein Gölfchen, ist das verhältnismäßig schnell gelöscht. Das sieht dann nachher verhältnismäßig, sieht dann natürlich nachher irgendwie traurig aus.
Ja, damit ist zu rechnen, da habt ihr ja auch wenig Einfluss drauf nun.
Und dann ist das so ein Auto brennt im Normalfall ganz verhältnismäßig schnell aus. Also wenn dann die Elektronik voran alles mal am Brennen ist, kannst du nicht mehr viel machen. Zumal dann der Schaden einfach da ist, wenn die Elektronik weg ist, die ganzen Kabel verschmort, das ist im Normalfall bereits ein Totalschaden.
Wie häufig hat man so mit Verletzten und, wie heißt es so schön, Personenschaden zu tun?
Ja, Personenschaden ist jetzt so irgendwie bis in die letzte Zeit irgendwie auf Zug gefahren. Da kennt man ja den Begriff wegen Personenschaden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich es herhabe. Das ist ja so Bahn-Terminologie.
Genau. Wirklich Einsätze mit eingeklemmten Personen, was einfach auf der, wenn man sich selbst eine Skala macht, ist eigentlich für einen so irgendwie das nicht gerade schrecklichste, aber so das negativ gesagt aufregendste, was einem passieren kann. Also wirklich Verkehrsunfall mit eingeklemmter Person ist halt schon im Normalfall, dass man sagt, da kommt jetzt was auf uns zu. Selten.
Aber ist schon mal vorgekommen.
Kommt schon vor. Was haben wir im Normalfall? 1-2 pro Jahr? Also es hält sich im Rahmen so oftmals auch nicht wirklich schlimm. Das sind vielleicht 3-4 Einsätze, dass auch nur jemand wirklich im Pkw ist und die die Tür einfach nicht mehr aufkriegen von eben. Das muss auch gar nicht viel passiert sein, aber es kann auch mal passiert sein, dass natürlich ein Auto sich irgendwo unter einem Baum wickelt. Und dann kann das auch mal in einer Stunde Arbeit vor Ort, anderthalb aus atmen, bis das alles erledigt ist.
Das ist ja auch eine nicht unerhebliche psychologische Belastung.
Das sind die Einsätze, die einen dann schon eher belasten, wenn man das dann mitkriegt, wenn natürlich der Rettungsdienst noch parallel mit einem mitarbeitet. Man arbeitet dann zusammen am Patienten. Und im Normalfall ist dann auch so, dass der Rettungsdienst dann ihren Teil des Einsatzes übernimmt in Absprache mit dem Einsatzleiter Feuerwehr, dass man sagt, okay, jetzt dürft ihr dran oder sägt bitte jetzt noch nicht hier auf. Den Patienten müssen wir erst noch ruhig stellen oder so, dass dann auch einfach die Zusammenarbeit, wie sie klappen muss.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo Personen zu Schaden kommen, wird sowieso auch nochmal separaten Rettungswagen gerufen, der jetzt so mit der Feuerwehr nichts zu tun hat?
Das hat mit uns im Normalfall nichts zu tun. Das macht der Disponent auf der Leitstelle, der einfach weiß, im Verkehrsunfall kommt sowieso ein Rettungswagen dazu. Mit eingeklemmten Personen, wie viele, so und so viel, okay, vielleicht zwei Rettungswagen dazu. Zusätzlich noch ein Notarzt, wenn es nötig ist. Oder dann vielleicht auch sogar, wenn es was Größeres ist, dann schon ein bisschen eine größere Organisationseinheit vom Rettungsdienst, einer, der das dann für die auch nochmal übergreifend managt.
Aber ihr habt natürlich auch alle so die Grundausbildung, also man geht sicherlich über erste Hilfe hinaus, oder was man so genießt?
Im Normalfall machen wir also mindestens einmal im Jahr einen normalen Erste-Hilfe-Lehrgang. Oder einfach laufend immer mal wieder was. Aber es ist nicht so, dass man sagen müsste, okay, jeder hat grundsätzlich und immer irgendwie einen Sanitäterlehrgang oder sowas.
Also schon nochmal separat.
Genau.
Aber wie ist das? Ich meine, ich weiß ja nicht, was du jetzt da schon selber erlebt hast, wir jetzt ja auch nicht einen großen Rumbohren, aber gibt es so eine Art Konzept für eine psychologische Vorbereitung oder im schlimmsten Fall auch Nachbereitung? Ich meine, man muss ja da auch schon so ein bisschen feuerfest sein, nicht nur in Bezug auf das Physikalische.
Also für die Vorbereitung, Einsatzvorbereitung, denke ich, kriegt man das einfach in der Grundausbildung auch schon beigebracht. Es kann darum gehen und dass man einfach immer wieder sagt, hör zu, wenn ihr ein Problem habt, einfach sprecht mit uns. Wir haben jetzt auch bei uns in der Feuerwehr speziell auch im Landkreis speziell ausgebildetes Personal, dass für so eine Einsatznachbereitung auch Leute da sind, die dann die Einsatzgriffe betreuen würden, psychologisch, wenn es Probleme gibt, dass wir mit denen reden können, das nochmal durchsprechen können, die auch dann vorbeikommen. Also da die Einsatznachbereitung, wenn wirklich psychologisch was sein sollte, die ist vorhanden, die kann geleistet werden. Auch gerade, weil wirklich im Normalfall das Belastendste meistens einfach wirklich so ein Verkehrsunfall ist. Oder auch ekliger noch, schlimmer noch natürlich auch ein Brand, wo man noch eine Person findet. Und das ist gerade für die, die die Person gefunden haben, für den Trupp vorhanden, ist natürlich belastend, klar. Schlimmer noch, wenn es dann auch noch vielleicht Bekannte wären, dann wird es dann natürlich ausartend.
Ja, oder Kinder oder sonst irgendwas, was einen mitnimmt. Abgesehen jetzt von, du hast ja schon so ein paar Fälle genannt, womit ihr euch so beschäftigt. Jetzt haben wir auch mal so diesen Einsatz irgendwie durchgespielt. Ich glaube, da kriegt man schon so ein bisschen Gefühl für den Takt, der da herrscht und so. Und auch die Bereitschaft, die da mit reinkommt. Was sind denn noch so Aufgaben, die auf euch zukommen, weil da Feuerwehr, die jetzt von dem, was wir bisher so genannt haben, noch nicht so tangiert werden? Hast du noch was Schönes auf deiner Liste?
Was kommt noch dazu? Einfache Sachen, ein Baum über die Straße, weil gerade mal wieder Sturmsaison ist.
Ahja, Naturkatastrophen.
Genau, also fangen wir bei der kleinen Naturkatastrophe an. Es ist ein Baum über eine Straße. Na gut, rausfahren, links und rechts ein Schnitt, das Zeug auf die Seite, weiter lachen. Ja, und wenn es dann der etwas größere Sturm ist, sprich Lothar oder so was, was vor ein paar Jahren hier mal durchgezogen ist, dann ist das einfach ein bisschen mehr. Und dann hat gleich mal irgendwie so ein ganzer Landkreis einfach zu tun.
Also bei solchen Bedingungen, da seid ihr dann sozusagen nur noch dabei.
Genau, wenn es dann wirklich so weit geht, dass es dann irgendwann zu gefährlich wird, dass man sagt, okay, bleibt da aber, geht bitte nicht. Oder fahren wir anders an, es kann aber auch so weit gehen, dass man dann irgendwann sagt, okay, die Straße bleibt jetzt erstmal gesperrt. Solange es so weiter stimmt, gehen wir jetzt nicht weiter. Lassen das so. Dumm Nummer, wenn es dann heißt, da sind aber noch zwei Leute angerufen, da sind noch zwei PKWs drin, dann sollte man sich dann doch reintrauen und zumindest die Person retten. Das Auto lassen wir da mal schön stehen, aber die Person irgendwie retten. Umsonsten Naturkatastrophen, einen Baum umgekippt, Hochwasser gehört auch dazu zu den klassischen Aufgaben.
Da kann es ja auch mal sein, dass man eigentlich über mehrere Tage dauerbelastet ist.
Hatten wir zum Glück noch nicht. Aber so der klassische Fall Oder-Hochwasser, das war jetzt allerdings zumindest für uns hier nicht eine Aufgabe von der Feuerwehr, sondern da sind dann Einheiten, lokale Einheiten vom Technischen Hilfswerk, wirklich dort hoch an die Oder gefahren und haben dort ausgeholfen über mehrere Tage.
Und Bundeswehr war da glaube ich auch mit dabei, oder?
Das läuft da natürlich mit ein, das ist da der selber Auftraggeber, beides der Bund.
Wie ist denn das Verhältnis von THW zu Feuerwehr?
Ich kann jetzt für uns unten sprechen, das Verhältnis ist gut.
Ich meinte nicht, ob es gut oder schlecht ist, sondern worum kümmert sich das THW, warum sich die Feuerwehr nicht kümmert. Auf den ersten Blick erscheinen mir die Aufgaben doch ähnlich gelagert zu sein, oder?
Wenn wir jetzt wirklich in Technik-Sachen kommen, sprich umgefallene Bäume oder irgendwo ist irgendwas eingestürzt, da kommt dann wirklich die Überschneidung zu THW und Feuerwehr. Sobald es technisch wird, auch Wasserrettung, kann auch eine Sache vom THW sein.
Keller auspumpen.
Genau, unser THW hat auch zwei Boote, hat auch Pumpen in rauen Mengen, hat Rüstmaterial, das heißt, die können auch irgendwas abstützen, die können auch mal in Häuser abgedeckt wurden, die haben auch einen Zug, der sich darum kümmert, dann so Schadenssicherung zu machen, eingeschlagene Scheiben, abgedeckte Dächer, die abzudecken. Also dort sind einfach, die Überschneidungen sind da. Und bei uns ist auch so, dass ab einem größeren Einsatz auch immer ein Fachberater, sogenannter vom THW, dazukommt, der einfach dann auch entscheiden kann, okay, das wäre jetzt eine Aufgabe, die könnten wir vom THW übernehmen, die sie dann auch mit übernehmen, auch um, mal ganz einfach gesagt, um das THW zu mehr Einsätzen auch zu verhelfen.
Ach, haben die zu wenig zu tun oder was?
Die hätten sonst, verhältnismäßig kann sein, dass sie einfach wenig zu tun haben, das THW schreibt eher mal eine Rechnung. Das liegt vielleicht auch daran, dass es einfach weniger bestellt, dass sie vielleicht auch weniger bekannt sind. Und daher dann einfach sagt, im Normalfall ruft halt jemand irgendwann, ich brauche die Feuerwehr wegen irgendwas, ist dann die Frage, weiß ich nicht, ob der Leitstellendisponent auch sagen würde, wir hätten aber das THW, was da eher helfen könnte. Kann ich nicht so genau sagen, es hat eine Bundeseinrichtung, werden zum Beispiel unser THW verhältnismäßig oft gerufen, wenn die Polizei irgendwo mal wieder eine große Straßenkontrolle macht, wenn die mit einem Fahrzeug von ihnen gerufen, um auszuleuchten. Diese Einsatzstelle dann. Oder letztens einen Erdrutsch bei uns an der Bahnlinie gab, wann irgendwie anderthalb Wochen lang jede Nacht irgendwie THW vor Ort ist, auszuleuchten.
Technisches Hilfswerk, wie der Name schon sagt.
Genau, Bundesanstalt, Technisches Hilfswerk, ist also eine Bundeseinrichtung.
Die dann eben auch im Katastrophenfall natürlich zum Einsatz kommen.
Genau.
Aber trotzdem, heißt das, dass das dann jetzt beim Oder-Hochwasser die Feuerwehren als solche gar nicht im Einsatz waren? Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Doch, die lokalen Feuerwehren waren natürlich im Einsatz. Aber es waren jetzt in dem Sinne nicht, soweit ich das jetzt sagen kann, waren zumindest jetzt nicht aus hier unten im Süden irgendwelche Feuerwehren, die gesagt haben, wir fahren da hoch.
Das ist ja klar, das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert. Ich wollte eigentlich auf was anderes hinaus. Nämlich, wenn sich jetzt so eine Notsituation einstellt. Ich meine, sagen wir mal, hier ist auch wieder Sturm. Und es ist mal so richtig Sturm. So, was weiß ich, Tausende von Bäumen knicken um, Pipapo, Häuser stürzen ein. Dann gibt es hier irgendwie noch eine Springflut. Eine Springflut ist hier vielleicht eher selten. Aber eine, was weiß ich auch, eine Hochwassersituation. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie es hier in der Region gelagert ist. Aber es kann ja immer mal irgendwie ein bisschen mehr Wasser runterkommen, als das Gelände so auszuhalten, in der Lage ist. Und es ist jetzt einfach mal Land unter und Krise und Panik. Was würde das dann bedeuten für die Freiwillige Feuerwehr? Würdet ihr dann irgendwie auch mal zwei Tage nicht zur Arbeit gehen und dann irgendwie permanent da nur eingebunden sein? Oder wird dann nur nachts gearbeitet?
Also letztendlich würde dann so was irgendwann einen Katastrophenalarm ausgerufen werden vom Landkreis. Das ist eine Landkreisgeschichte. Der ruft dann sozusagen den Katastrophenalarm aus. Dann gibt es dort auch wieder einen Stab, der diese Aufgaben abwickeln würde. Und dort ist dann auch im Normalfall Feuerwehr dabei, ist Rettungsdienst dabei, steht die Polizei, ist THW dabei. Und die landen dann die Aufgaben und werden dann einfach entsprechend zugeschustert. Und natürlich wird dann auch jeder im Rahmen seiner Sachen die Aufgaben abkriegen, was letztendlich auch heißen kann, dass man dann auch als Feuerwehr mal zwei Tage irgendwie nicht arbeiten geht.
Und ist das dann in irgendeiner Form gedeckt, dass die Leute dann irgendwie ihre Jobs einbüßen, weil dann der Chef sagt, du bist mir ein bisschen zu häufig beim Löschen?
Grundsätzlich würde die Feuerwehr Lohnausfall zahlen. Das ist die eine Sache. Allerdings kann dann der Chef natürlich immer noch sagen, ja, ihr habt mir zwar Lohnausfall gezahlt, aber der war halt trotzdem nicht arbeiten. Und das ist natürlich eine Sache, die heutzutage immer öfter vorkommt, dass die Kollegen dann einfach sagen, hört mal zu, wenn jetzt tagsüber was ist, ich sehe ja, was es ist, ich werde nur noch bei größeren Sachen kommen, weil wenn ich irgendwie andauernd wegrenne, wird der Chef langsam hellhörig.
Also ist ein Problem.
Er muss dich an und für sich gehen lassen, aber irgendwann sagt er auch mal, jetzt ist Schluss.
Ja, darauf wollt ihr auch noch hinaus. Also rechtlich gibt es sozusagen, in dem Moment gibt es eine Absicherung für jemanden, der in der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr ist.
Also das Landesfeuerwehrgesetz sagt halt, der Arbeitgeber hat dich irgendwie freizustellen für Einsätze und Übungsdienst und so weiter. Nur irgendwann sagt er halt jetzt mal Schluss mit Freistellen. Verstehe. Er muss dich zwar gehen lassen, man sagt, okay, ich muss dich gehen lassen, aber ich muss dich nicht weiter beschäftigen. Und das ist einfach der Zwiespalt. Und natürlich wird natürlich auch der Lohnausfall entsprechend, wie gesagt, auch gezahlt werden. Was jetzt irgendwie je teurer der Arbeiter ist, der Mitarbeiter ist, natürlich umso teurer für die Feuerwehr wird. Im Gegensatz dazu werden zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt jemand angestellt bei einer Gemeinde ist oder beim Land oder beim Bund, wird kein Lohnausfall gezahlt. Die sind also verhältnismäßig günstig. Aber irgendwann ist einfach für den Arbeitgeber dann die Grenze erreicht, dass er sagt, es ist ja gut, dass du in der Feuerwehr bist, aber mach doch mal bitte ein bisschen langsamer da.
Jetzt haben wir vorhin schon eine Menge auch über Kommunikation geredet. Da gab es dann irgendwie den Leitwagen und da wird dann auch gefunkt. Funk scheint ja ohnehin auch so ein spezielles Nerd-Thema innerhalb der ganzen Feuerwehr-Geschichte zu sein. Ich leite das jetzt einfach mal ganz banal von der Beobachtung ab, dass zumindest bei dem Zert, dem schon eingangs erwähnten, der Querschnitt zwischen Teilnehmern an der Gruppe und den Funkern doch relativ groß ist. Das scheint doch schon nochmal so ein besonderer Hobbysport im Hobbysport zu sein, oder?
Nein, also ja und nein, würde ich jetzt mal einfach sagen, es gehört einfach dazu, es ist Arbeitsmittel. Jeder Trupp, zwei Mann, der im Normalfall allein für sich unterwegs ist, hat ein Funkgerät dabei, das er erreichbar ist, das er Meldungen abgeben kann, Aufträge bekommen kann. Jedes Fahrzeug hat ein fest eingebautes Funkgerät. Nach oben hin natürlich immer weiter. Das ist Arbeitsmittel in erster Situation. Und für den, der sich gerne ein bisschen mehr darüber informiert, der arbeitet halt gerne damit. Also die Möglichkeiten, ich hab mit Funk irgendwie viel zu tun, ich will jetzt gerne in der Feuerwehr mehr mit Funk machen, die sind verhältnismäßig begrenzt. Man kann natürlich sagen, okay, du bist dann der bei uns, der halt vielleicht mal die Funkgeräte repariert oder so, wenn er auch noch ein elektronisches Verständnis hat. Aber irgendwo, das hat halt ein Ende. Du kannst sagen, okay, jetzt im Einsatzfall ist der dann halt vielleicht der, der in diesem Einsatzleitwagen sitzt, am Funk hockt, viel Funk, viel mitschreibt, dass er dort dann noch entsprechend genutzt werden kann, oder seinen Wunsch entsprochen werden kann, oder einfach in größeren Einsätzen, in größeren Funkzentralen noch verwendet werden kann. Aber irgendwo ist halt dann für uns erst mal nur ein Arbeitsmittel. Kein Sinn zum Zweck, wir gehen nicht in die Feuerwehr zum Funken.
Aber du bist auch so ein bisschen funkaffin?
Ich bin ein bisschen funkaffin, ich bin nebenbei noch Funkamateur. Das ist auch noch so ein kleines Hobby. Bin aber auch zusätzlich noch Ausbilder für Sprechfunk in der Feuerwehr.
Ah, das heißt, du bringst den Leuten bei, wie sie sich auf dem Kanal zu verhalten haben?
Ich bringe ihnen bei, was wir für Geräte haben, wie sie mit denen umzugehen haben, wie sie sich an dem Gerät mit dem Gerät zu verhalten haben.
Jetzt generell Ausbildung oder speziell ist das ein Teil von dieser Jugendausbildung schon?
Nein, das ist nachher die Ausbildung, die sie nach ihrer Grundausbildung als ersten Lehrgang machen sollten.
Was muss man denen so beibringen?
Wie sie die Funkgeräte bedienen, was für Tasten hat, dass sie Kanäle wechseln können, wie denn so ein Funkgespräch ablaufen soll, wer zuerst, wer dann, wie die Funkrufnamen heißen. Aber das ist auch ein Beibringen, sag ich jetzt mal, wie für den Führerschein. Okay, ihr dürft's, ihr könnt's auch ein bisschen, aber die Übung muss einfach noch kommen. Ganz klar, weil man in zwei Samstagen einem das nicht irgendwie aus dem FFF beibringen kann. Die Grundlagen, na klar, sie können's auch. Nur das flüssige Umgehen damit, dass man nicht mehr nachdenken muss, was mache ich jetzt hier überhaupt, dass man das einfach verwendet, kommt natürlich später.
Ziel ist vor allem, aber auch hier wieder klare Kommunikation in kurzer Zeit.
Genau, dass einfach die Kommunikation, die ich möchte, einfach funktioniert.
So, mal kurz zwischendurch. Haben wir noch was? Du guckst so ein bisschen.
Ja, sind halt auch ein paar Minuten.
Ja, wir sind jetzt auch eigentlich so, ich habe jetzt hier so meine kleinen Strichliste abgearbeitet. Ja, soweitgehend jetzt die Frage, also das einzige, was mir jetzt noch einfallen würde, nachzufragen, wäre jetzt so Spezialfeuerwehren gekauft und sowas. Und fällt dir sonst noch was ein, was man jetzt unbedingt noch erwähnen müsste?
Noch viele Fahrzeuge ausgelassen, aber ich denke, da könnte man natürlich endlos erzählen.
Ja, irgendwelche ganz wirklich wichtigen Fahrzeuge.
Eine Drehleiter, aber das ist halt auch nur irgendwie eine Leiter, die halt automatisch ausfährt und irgendwie Räder drunter hat.
Ja, nö, ich meine, klar könnte man das noch beliebig vertiefen.
Naja, Flughafenfeuerwehr, das sind dann halt die Löschfahrzeuge, die nun mal größer und sitzen auf einmal viel weniger Leute drauf.
Naja, vielleicht können wir das ja damit ausklingen lassen. Also ich meine, wir haben dann noch zwei Stunden voll irgendwie, das ist so schlecht nicht.
Ja, ich schneide erstmal meine ganzen As raus und so.
So waren gar nicht so viele, zumindest keine, die mir jetzt unangenehm aufgefallen wären. Ja, jetzt haben wir ja schon eine ganze Menge zusammengetragen. Ich denke, es zeichnet sich schon auch ein ganz guter Blick ab, was so eigentlich der Aufgabenfeld der Freiwilligen Feuerwehr ist, die Berufsfeuerwehren. Ich meine, das kann man sich jetzt schnell, glaube ich, dazu reimen. Das ist dann im Prinzip das Ganze nur eben mit einem höheren Maß an Verpflichtungen. Andere Aufgaben übernehmen die jetzt auch nicht als die Freiwilligen.
Grundlegend eigentlich nicht.
Oder gibt es irgendwas, wofür die ausgebildet sind, wo dann die Freiwillige Feuerwehr sagt, da muss jetzt hier mal... Ihr habt ja kaum Berufsfeuerwehren um euch herum.
Genau, es kann sein, dass die, je nach Ort, dass die Feuerwehr, die Berufsfeuerwehr, auch noch den Rettungsdienst fährt. Das ist also, wenn du jetzt einen Rettungswagen bestellst, das auf dem Feuerwehr, Berufsfeuerwehr München zum Beispiel draufsteht. Das heißt dann, in München fährt auch die Berufsfeuerwehr noch Rettungsdienst dazu. Das hat denen delegiert worden. Das macht halt dort nicht nur das Rote Kreuz, das macht halt auch noch die Feuerwehr und auch die Matheser. Das ist einfach so als Aufgaben, was im Normalfall auf dem Land eine Freiwege eher nicht macht.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch spezialisierte Feuerwehren. Mir würde jetzt als erstes Flughafenbedarf einfallen. Weißt du was darüber?
Ja, also weiß darüber. Man hat natürlich in gewissem Maße ein professionelles Interesse daran. Ich war jetzt auch schon mal zumindest in Zürich, die Flughafenfeuerwehr anschauen. Letztendlich ist es auch eine Berufsfeuerwehr oder man könnte es sozusagen eine Werksfeuerwehr. Das heißt, ein Flughafen ist verpflichtet, eine Feuerwehr zu stellen.
Weil er einfach ein Ort der besonderen Gefährdung ist?
Weil er ein besonderes Verfahren hat natürlich.
Das gilt dann auch für Industrie?
Industrien, in gewisser Rahmen weiß ich nicht, ob sie wirklich immer verpflichtet sind, eine zu stellen. Aber es ist ganz einfach ein Trade-off. Entweder die Versicherung sagt denen, jetzt hat man es fünffache oder jetzt setzt euch eine Feuerwehr hin. Dann wird es für euch wieder ein bisschen billiger.
Also BASF hat bestimmt eigene.
Die haben in jedem Standort große Feuerwehren. Es lohnt sich natürlich, für ein großes, zum Beispiel Chemiewerk, eine Feuerwehr zu haben. Diese Feuerwehrleute, die arbeiten je nachdem, wenn sie nicht dauerhaft Feuerwehr spielen dort, die arbeiten vor Ort, die kennen sich im Gebäude aus. Eine Feuerwehr aus der Gemeinde, aus dem Ort, die jetzt erst geholt werden müsste, die kennt sich nicht aus. Da muss man erst sagen, wo sie hin, da muss man immer einen dabei stellen, dass sie wissen, hier dürfte hin, hier lauern die und die gefahren. Das hat natürlich Schwervorteile für ein großes Unternehmen, eine Werksfeuer zu haben. Und im Umkehrschluss, dann natürlich auch die Fortsetzung davon, ist dann die Flughafenfeuerwehr, die dann spezielle Löschgeräte hat. Also so viele spezielle Löschgeräte, nicht spezielle Löschfahrzeuge hat, für den Einsatz auf dem Flughafen, die einfach verhältnismäßig schnell sind. Die Geräte fahren dann schon mal 80 oder 100. Und da sitzt dann aber auf so einem Löschfahrzeug nur noch zwei Personen drauf. Das heißt, einer fährt das irgendwie hin, und einer kümmert sich dann um die ganzen Löscharbeiten.
Worauf sind die optimiert? Also sind die jetzt noch mal besonders auf Geschwindigkeit optimiert?
Auf Durchsatz, also viel löschen in kurzer Zeit irgendwie schnell hin, reinspringen und dann irgendwie auch gar nicht mehr aussteigen. Die bleiben alle in ihrem Fahrzeug sitzen.
Und löschen einfach direkt aus dem Fahrzeug heraus?
Löschen einfach aus dem Fahrzeug, ist alles drin. Ich kann sagen, okay, ich hätte gern Schaum, dann Joystick, mit dem man dann diese Monitore sozusagen, heißen die, die steuert, okay, nach rechts, nach links, ein bisschen weiter, um einfach den Löschteil, einfach in den Pflichten, die sie haben, die ihnen durchs Luftfahrtgesetz wahrscheinlich oder irgendwie so auferlegt werden. Wenn was ist, müsste dann so und so viele Minuten da sein, um das einfach abzudecken. Und da wurde dann spezielle Hardware dafür gebaut. Das sind auch die Flughafenfeuerwehr-Rücken, zum Teil auch nach außerhalb aus. Weil man auch da sagt, okay, dort ist Material vorhanden. Und wenn es jetzt irgendwie außenrum brennt, um den Flughafen rum, kann es durchaus sein, dass auch mal ein Löschfahrzeug von der Flughafenfeuerwehr im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten, wenn sie sagen, okay, das brauchen wir jetzt gerade da nicht. Wir können mit den vorhandenen Fahrzeugen das auch abdecken, und das soll, dass auch das mal vor die Tür fährt und dort irgendwo aushilft.
Dafür sind die auch zugelassen und geeignet?
Natürlich, das ist immer noch ein zugelassenes Fahrzeug, hat eine Straßenzulassung. Ganz klar.
Also immer so auf dem Flughafen bleibt ja so einiges rum, was keiner hat, ne?
Sie machen einfach keine, weil es nicht nötig ist, weil die auf Privatgelände bleiben.
Aber halt die Feuerwehr schon.
Genau.
Ja, was bleibt? Also wir haben jetzt wahrscheinlich 1000 Sachen ausgelassen, die auch noch vielleicht ganz interessant sind, aber ich wollte halt hier erst mal so ein bisschen Einblick bieten in das Thema, hatten wir ja hier noch irgendwie überhaupt nicht bei CRE. Was, was haben wir denn noch? Irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen, dass du noch...
Ich schau mal gerade auf so eine Spickliste, eine kleine, müsste aber jetzt im Moment eigentlich nicht so viel. Ausbildung, haben wir das gut genug gemacht?
Naja, aber du kannst ja vielleicht mal nochmal so ein bisschen an die Jugend appellieren und was mich ja auch schon so eingangs so ein bisschen interessiert hat oder überhaupt so in der Essenz interessiert hat. Was ist der Reiz? Was macht Feuerwehr, freiwillige Feuerwehr so interessant? Ich meine, ich höre jetzt so verschiedene Sachen raus. Das ist halt erstmal aufregend. Es hat viel mit Technik zu tun. Es hat viel mit Organisation zu tun, mit Logistik zu tun. Also ich weiß ja wenig darüber, aber mein Gefühl ist immer, dass man da einfach eine ganze Menge lernen kann, was eben auch, sagen wir mal, jetzt ein Wissen ist, was einem auch über die Feuerwehrtätigkeit hinaus einfach was mitgibt.
Wie siehst du das? Was wir jetzt einfach ausgelassen haben, würde ich sagen, ist natürlich den Begriff, den vielleicht mal gehört hat, Kameradschaft, aber auch der Zusammenhalt innerhalb der Kameraden, die dort sitzen, der Feuerwehrleute, dass man einfach sagt, okay, man sitzt zusammen, man kann miteinander reden. Das ist einfach der Zusammenhalt, der zugehört. Dein Job kann dir lang gefallen, auch im Büro irgendwie, wenn du aber mit den Kollegen im Büro nicht auseinanderkommst, mit denen ich umgehen kann, dann macht die ganze Sache auch keinen Spaß. Und letztendlich ist auch das in der Feuerwehr, auch das mal zusammen hocken oder mal einen Ausflug zusammen machen. Wenn du nachher miteinander arbeiten musst und im Fahrzeug oder irgendwas was löschen, willst du eigentlich mit dem, der da neben dir sitzt oder hinter dir steht, auch auskommen.
Und den, der dich mit der Umstände aus der Scheiße holt.
Genau, genau deswegen.
Wenn irgendwie das Haus über dir zusammenbricht. Das heißt, es ist auch ein Kulturkreis und auch ein soziales Leben, was man dort führt.
Es ist natürlich ein Kulturkreis, soziales Leben. Wie gesagt, gehören Ausflüge dazu oder man trifft sich halt auch mal nur zum Ein-Zusammen-Trinken. Natürlich, wie in jedem Verein.
Wie in jedem Verein. Also halt so ein bisschen auch was von Vereinsatmosphäre. Aber eine Kehlbahn habt ihr nicht bei euch im Leben.
Nein, nicht so ein Verein. Es gibt einen Wettbewerb zwischen Feuerwehr und anderen Vereinen. Also wer kriegt, wie hat es auch noch gesagt, bei den Jugendlichen fällt es am meisten auf, wer erreicht die Jugendlichen möglichst früh, um sie halt für seine Sache so ein bisschen zu interessieren. Und klar, Fußball ist da einfach viel besser dran, weil die nehmen die Kids schon irgendwie mit sechs. Und da hat die Feuerwehr einfach noch vier Jahre Wartezeit. Du kannst mit Sechsjährigen noch nicht wirklich anfangen.
Ja, aber die Kindergärten, die kommen immer gerne zu Besuchen.
Die Kindergärten kommen immer gerne zu Besuch. Die Schulen kommen immer gerne vorbei. es ist einfach auf dem Lehrplan der Schulen. Das muss in irgendeiner Klasse auch mal besprochen werden, Feuerwehr. Und da macht man auch mal was, klar.
Inwieweit trägt denn die Feuerwehr sonst noch Wissen in die Gesellschaft? Was wir nur angekratzt haben, so Brandvorschriften, Brandverhütung, ich meine, dieses ganze Präventive. Im Prinzip ist man ja immer besser dran, wenn man den Schaden, den die Feuerwehr dann ausrubbeln kann, gar nicht erst hat. Inwiefern ist das auch Teil der Arbeit der freiwilligen Feuerwehren? Fällt das irgendwie mit rein, dass ihr so in die Schulen geht oder dass ihr andere Fortbildungsmaßnahmen bietet oder sonst wie versucht, Prävention ins Volk zu bringen?
Das gehört teils mit dazu natürlich, dass man auch mal sagt, okay, man bietet für die Bevölkerung irgendwie Schulungen, Umgang im Feuerlöscher. Bildet aus? Nein. Bietet der Bevölkerung Schulungen im Umgang mit Feuerlöscher. Viele haben vielleicht einen im Keller stehen, wissen aber nicht, wie sie damit umgehen müssen, wie nah darf ich ans Feuer ran? Macht der was? Werd ich dreckig, wenn ich den verwende? Ist das gefährlich? Und dann bietet man immer mal wieder an, macht irgendwo einen Stand bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung und erklärt mal ein bisschen über die Züge von Rauchmeldern, Rauch- und Brandmeldern, dass man, wenn man so einen Rauch- und Brandmelder bei sich zu Hause hat, dass der sich halt meldet, bevor man schon in seinem Bett erstickt ist.
Das ist eine gute Idee, ne?
Auch wenn der eine oder andere vielleicht nicht so gut damit umgehen kann, sagt er, zu viel Fehlararme oder sonst irgendwas. Aber im Grundsatz denke ich, es hilft.
Ja, lieber ein Fehlararm zu viel als ein Alarm zu wenig.
Und wenn ich es richtig weiß, in Berlin ist es glaube ich mittlerweile so weit, dass in Neubauten oder Umbauten schon Rauchmelder verbaut werden müssen. Das ist eine Ländersache, das ist auf Länderebene. In manchen Baugesetzgebungen ist es mit drin, dass das jetzt in Neubauten einfach mit rein muss. Baden-Württemberg nicht. Entscheidend andere.
So, und dann vielleicht so als letzte Frage, der Nerdcomputer-Keller, was sollte der sich für einen Feuerlöscher hinstellen?
Der Nerdcomputer-Keller.
Es gibt doch so, weiß nicht, so Elektronik und so. Hat doch immer so seine ganz eigenen Bedürfnisse, oder?
CO2-Löscher, also Kohlendioxid. Denn du willst, glaube ich, dein Nerdcomputer-Keller oder dein privates Hosting im Schuhschrank willst du nicht irgendwie mit so einem guten alten Pulverlöscher noch versauen. Das heißt, CO2-Löscher ist im Normalfall das, was ich sagen würde, für Gebäude, für Innen ist einfach das Beste.
Das heißt, das ist einfach nur ein Drucktank mit CO2 drin. Das heißt, man erstickt einfach Flammen, dadurch, dass einfach der Sauerstoff...
Mit Kälte und genau.
Mit Kälte.
Ja, weil das beim Ausbreiten natürlich kalt wird. Beim sich Ausweiten.
Ah, okay. Das heißt, das ist der wesentliche Löscheffekt, die Kältebildung oder einfach so...
Die Kälte und das Ersticken.
Und die Erstickung, okay, also in Kombination. Und den muss man sich kaufen und dann wie häufig...
Den kaufst du da im Normalfall Aufkleber drauf, wie lang der irgendwie gewartet werden muss. Im Normalfall als zu alle zwei Jahre warten lassen. Hilft auch ungemein, mit irgendeiner Firma halt auch einen Vertrag auszumachen, dass die sich dann melden und der allgemeinen Verpeilung einfach vorbeugen. Sonst irgendwie, wenn du einen... Oder wenn ihr einen im Haus stehen habt, irgendwie einen Feuerlöscher, schaut mal drauf, was ist denn drin? Wenn ABC-Pulver draufsteht, dann würde ich ihn irgendwie mal auswechseln gegen einen CO2-Löscher.
Weil das...
Denn die Sauerei, wenn wirklich so ein Pulverlöscher schon mal in der Wohnung abgeblasen wird, ist...
Da ist die Wohnung nicht mehr zu gebrauchen, ja. Wofür braucht man diese Pulverteile eigentlich? Oder ist das nur alte Technologie?
Die kann man draußen... Also jetzt öffentlich für einen Pkw-Brand kann man die wunderbar verwenden, weil das durch das Löschpulver einfach abdeckt. Aber denk einfach dran, du willst irgendwie sechs Kilo Salz einfach mal bei dir irgendwie im Raum verteilen, einfach mit Hochdruck. Die sind nachher überall.
Die kriegt man nicht wieder weg.
Das heißt halt nachher erst mal irgendwie putzen. Du wirst zwar, wenn es ein Brand ist, wirklich noch den Rauch und so drin haben und vielleicht auch mal Ruß, aber du hast ihn einfach nicht weiter noch versaut.
Okay. CO2-Löscher, das ist der Tipp.
Das würde ich mal sagen.
Genau, soll ja keiner sagen, es gibt keinen praktischen Nutzen, Chaosradio Express zu hören. Neben all der Theorie auch noch praktische Empfehlung. Tja, dann sag ich mal, lassen wir die Rolltore wieder runter, oder? Peter, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zur Feuerwehr, zur Freiwilligen und sonstigen und wie man einen Brand löscht und vielleicht am besten gar nicht erst entstehen lässt. Ich hoffe, das war interessant und bedanke mich fürs Zuhören und wünsche mir natürlich auch wieder Feedback bei uns im Blog, blogkaosradio.ch, cc.de. Das ist der Ort, wo die Kommentare hingehen sollten. Und wenn ihr Lust habt, kennt ihr ja, schreibt ja auch mal eine Mail an mich. Und vor allem schaltet ihr doch das nächste Mal wieder rein, wenn's heißt, bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.